geez
and mr chair i have
thank
you
ready to start
bringing your mr chair okay i don't have
a gavel so
i often knock on the table so
so i want to welcome you all to the
municipal and county government
committee
meeting this is our first
official meeting when we're going to
discuss legislation
this year
and i have
something i need to read to you because
of
the fact that we're doing a blended
meeting
as chair of the municipal county
government committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covert 19
pandemic in accordance with house 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public party is authorized to meet
electronically
this is the public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting
complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600
or email
hcs
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christina daya is the staff assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
it's anybody in the room with you during
we can't hear you
i believe that computer is muted if
sure
he has gone he may be back in a moment
representative
present and i am alone in the room in my
home however there are two other family
members in other parts of the house
did you just call me yesterday
i'm sorry i did not hear the whole thing
i'm head home in hillsborough alone in
the room now but my husband might wander
in with a cat or two
okay
representative
i love you representative mcdonald
that's a lovely pronunciation of my name
i'm here in dover alone in my home at
the moment thank you
i am uh in my house in my room in exeter
and i am alone but like uh
you may hear my husband in the
background
thank you uh welcome to the majority is
here
representative stillers
i am present and alone although
expecting
someone
shortly who will be moving around the
house possibly making noise
i'm here at my home alone in nashua and
my husband is at work and not in home
okay
trying i am unmuted there we go now can
you hear me
yes man
okay great
uh i am alone in the room that i am
sitting in my husband is here in the
house in another room and there are
i am here i am alone in my
office here
my husband is in the house and my two
greyhounds will make an appearance they
love to do that
thank you i can hear everybody
okay uh representative gallagher
i am
he was present mr second
see mr oh there he is
that's rejoined but it's muted right now
you're going to record you there okay
yeah yeah i'm
here thank you and representative melvin
here
all set yes sir
all right i would ask uh for the people
in the room and there's betsy kenneth at
remote locations to please join me in
even in this unusual format some
traditions are still happening that's
good
all right our first bill
that we're going to consider is hb 340
which is has to do with the designation
of open containers
on uh in municipal lands
uh i'd like to at this point
recognize the sponsor that bill
representative van
thank you mr chairman uh
so i'm actually here to ask the
committee to
pretty much instantly
itl this bill after i put it in because
uh during the coveted times my town
peterborough was struggling with how to
help local restaurants
and there was a lot of pushback
from the code officer and from various
public officials about well we couldn't
do this and we can't do that and we
can't do this other thing because
you know it violates the open container
law
so i thought okay well let's
let's offer a fix
so i
with the help of the um office of the
you know the drafting office i put this
bill together but friday i got a call
from
the
lawyer for the municipal committee uh
for sorry for the liquor commission and
the lawyer for the liquor commission
told me that actually towns and cities
and every jurisdiction already has the
ability to do what i was attempting to
do with this bill therefore the bill is
redundant
and i would like to ask the committee to
vote it and expedient to legislate
thank you representative ivey
at this point
i'm going to uh
close the
on hb 340 and open
an executive session
on 340.
uh
and i recognize represent representative
ivey to make a motion
it's representative van and i move that
we find this bill inexpedient to
legislate
i'm sorry on it's okay
everyone calls me ivy but it's really
bad it's my last name
my facial recognition software in my
head is a little weak especially with
all these masks so
uh i may have an issue with your
pronunciation of your names or
or if you're here to be able to see you
through the mask so until i get used to
that
please accept my apology in advance all
right we have a motion on the floor to
itl
hb 340 is in a second exactly
followed
by
at this point we're going to go to a
roll call vote i would ask you
to
register
yes or nay or no whether or not you
agree that this should be itl
did you call me
yes ma'am
i'm sorry what i'm hearing is
representative ort
so i'm not
that's what i'm hearing from where i am
so
you'll have to just remind me that
yes
you have to unmute yourself uh
representative mcbride
yes
representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative powell
representative gallagher
yes
representative
representative stavis
we're doing all these names today
representative monty putty woods yes
yes
this is uh 18-0
and you want this to go on the uh
consent calendar yes without objection
i'll place this on the consent calendar
mr chair can i ask again what was the
vote number
eighteen to zero
i'm only do we have 18 of our committee
members here
yes we're only missing uh representative
diamante who's in another meeting he'll
be here in about 30 minutes okay i'm
sorry i'm looking at the participant
list and i realize i'm ignoring the ones
okay any other questions on that that
was uh
an interesting process we we've
exercised
a hearing and an executive session
all-in-one
uh
that will not be typical we would not
have executive sessions at another time
okay we're going to move now back
out of executive session and back into
our hearings
and the next bill we're going to
consider is hp
459 which prohibits a transfer of funds
within an adopted budget
uh with details i believe
uh norm silver is here as the
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
okay yes
okay um
this is uh representative silber from
belknap2
uh there's some co-sponsors
uh from several uh from a couple of
different districts including bellap2
the issue here is
one dealing with the budgeting process
that takes place
in the counties
the schools the towns the cities
i've been chair of the budget committee
in my town for a while in the past
we just finished doing the budget in
belknap county by the delegation
so
i apologize for going through things
which many members of the committee if
not all might already know but i think
you need to take this all in context
the department of revenue administration
promulgates a chart of accounts that's
used by all the different entities that
has numerous general ledger accounts
and they use these general ledger
accounts to keep track of
not only expenditures but budgeting
items for each of each category of
expenditures
so what happens is in the budgeting
process
depending upon what which entity is
involved whether it's the county the
county commissioners produce a proposed
budget
in the schools the school board produces
a proposed budget in sb2 towns
the budget committee produces a proposed
budget
in other cities other other bodies may
produce a proposed budget in which
these numerous and sometimes in the
hundreds of line items general ledger
line items are shown in the budget and
they're up for approval in the case of
the county budget it has to be voted in
by the county delegation or convention
which just happened in belmont in the
case of the school boards and the towns
in sb2 towns they're presented as
warrant articles that are voted on by
the tax the voters in the towns and in
ins i
assume in some cities there the adoption
of the proposed budget is by
selectmen or whatever the board happens
to be called in the town
many times during the process of going
through the different budget items which
would have having all the requests
a determination is made
that a particular line item should be
zeroed out
and that means that nothing should be
spent in that particular category
so then the budget goes for approval
the budget is approved showing some line
items one or more line items with zero
in there and that's the budget that is
then adopted
then what happens is the particular
group whether it's the county the
schools the town
has to report on the adopted budget to
the dra and they use the forms that are
commonly known as the ms forms and the
ms forms report
by
conglomerating a lot of these individual
line items into a smaller number of
entry
lines on the ms forms so the ms forms
presently do not show the full detail of
the budget that has been approved by the
voters or the governing body
so
what we found happens is and after i
consulted with someone a staff at the
dra
is that they take the position that
even though an individual general ledger
line item has been zeroed out in the
approved budget approved by the
taxpayers by the the voters
that
the governing body still has the
authority to make transfers
into that road line item
as long as the total does not exceed the
total shown in that particular master
line on the ms forms
so what it means is that transfers can
be made into a line item
even though it's you know been prohibi
essentially prohibited by the voters so
the dra doesn't have the full story on
the ms forms so what this build does is
in three parts deals with this issue in
three parts
the first is requiring that in a as a
supplement to the ms forms
the reporting body
sends in a schedule of all of the
general ledger line items that have been
zeroed out and that's a supplement or
addendum to the ms form so the dra has
it
the second aspect of the bill is that it
expressly prohibits transfers
into line items that were in those in
general ledger line lines that were
zeroed out
and the third is an enforcement
mechanism which basically gives
the ability to challenge if a a transfer
has been made into a zeroed out line
item
it gives an enforcement mechanism to get
that money put back and to basically
prohibit a future action
now
what i found in working on the budget
committee for several years in my town
is that
the way to deal with the issue is if you
in your in the wisdom of the the budget
committee or the delegation
wants to preserve the right for the
governing body to transfer funds into a
line item that has little or nothing in
it as opposed to zero
we would put in a dollar as a we called
it a placeholder
so once that line item has a dollar in
it you can now make a transfer and
that's there's no problem because the
voters have approved the budget
containing that line item with a
placeholder in it with the full
knowledge that transfers can be made but
to
make a transfer into a line item with
zero in there
is really contrary to what the voters
have approved
so
uh
basically you know there's going to be
some opposition i'm sure there'll be
people who support it and there's going
to be people who oppose this and the
question i ask myself is why would
someone why would anyone or an
organization oppose this well people
would oppose this because they want the
ability
to override what the voters have said
in their
approval of a budget with a zero line
item
on a particular topic or particular area
of expenditure so what this does it
gives full transparency and full effect
to the votes to approve the budget by
the voters
uh representative
will you be able to stay with us for the
next 15 minutes or so or do you have a
place you gotta go i'm with you uh for
the for the long haul
okay what i'm gonna do is is uh
is ask a couple of more people who are
who have asked to speak to speak and
then we'll uh open it up for questions
for everybody is that okay with you
that's fine
and by the way i i did put on a tie and
a code today but even though i'm not on
video
very nice thank you so much
uh
next i'm going to uh recognize someone
who opposes the bill
and uh that will be justin campo
and then we'll go to after that becky
benvenuti and skip murphy i'll ask all
three of you to limit your testimony to
four minutes i know
skip you've asked for 10 but i'm gonna
hold you
to four
so uh
justin campbell you're up
hello can everyone hear me
yep you're good perfect
um i'd like to thank you for allowing me
this time to discuss this bill i am in
opposition of the bill
um as you're well aware a budget is a
financial plan of what the municipality
intends to do
i believe if this bill would be voted
into law that would end up backfiring on
the purpose that's intended to do with
this bill
we plan our budget months before it
actually goes into place and unlike the
private sector if something were to
happen that caused a shift
required a shift we would not have the
ability to do so i would say it was
voted by the public
speaking right now from this webcam is a
perfect example this time last year
there was zero thought about purchasing
webcams and laptops for town employees
in order to
maintain
the town hall during the uh pandemic
operation
um yet a worldwide pandemic hit and it
becomes a requirement if this bill were
to take place i would be looking at a
personal fine for doing what is best for
my taxpayers my job as a finance
director for the town of wandery is to
protect the people's tax dollars and be
as transparent as possible by showing
them where their money is spent
i believe in keeping historically
accurate expense records so it can
reflect the future budgets and be used
to plan where the tax dollars need to be
spent this bill doesn't reflect this and
i believe instead request expense be
hidden by charging them to inaccurate
accounts which is not fair to do to the
taxpayers
if passed my recommendation to my town
manager and town council was to budget
every single account line even if it has
not been used in years
at one dollar
uh and that to me is not transparent to
the taxpayers it doesn't reflect an
accurate budgeting document it makes it
less accurate and therefore less
transparent quaint and simple it goes
against my job my job is to be as
transparent as possible and show my
taxpayers where their money is being
spent and this bill tells me to do
otherwise
if house bill 459
as if passed house bill 4059 implies it
is more important to remain within the
financial planning plan made over one
year earlier than to be transparent to
my taxpayers it is an attempt to take
control at the state level over local
governments and tie the hands of local
governments preventing them from doing
what is best for their taxpayers
this doesn't consider the actual
functionality and annual expenses that
occur in local governments
currently when there is a need to
transfer funding to the general ledger
with the zero balance the finance
department would be required to explain
the reasoning and purpose behind it
should this bill pass the expense will
be charged on account where it does not
belong the municipality will no longer
be keeping historically accurate records
rsa 3195b which allows municipalities to
accept
and expend unanticipated revenues will
become an irrelevant statue further
encouraging west transparency should
this pass
if a town is anticipating the funding
whether it be from grants rebates or
state aid
there if they're not anticipating it
there's minimal chance it'll be budgeted
for meaning the account line will be
zero this bill will not allow the town
to accept the funding as the account was
budgeted at zero dollars
instead the town has potentially added
to an inaccurate account or pass on the
funding hurting the taxpayers further
i'm asked to maintain a budget of well
over 40 million dollars will manage over
100 million dollars with minimal staff
as section 32 5 e3 states in inadvertent
error a simple accidental mistake that
doesn't impact the bottom line but
rather a single account line
in which londonderry's general fund
alone has approximately over a thousand
will result in a civil fine men exist
large amount of money with less than
three staff members no longer seems
reasonable and require additional staff
further burdening my taxpayers this bill
will inspire less transparency and place
a larger tax burden on my taxpayers
instead of encouraging expenses to be
charged to be
to instead of encouraging expenses to be
charged to appropriate accounts
please allow me my cuisinart myself and
my counterparts to maintain and
encourage transparency i ask you to post
this bill as it allows towns and all out
towns to continue to act in the best
okay thank you uh mr campo you you met
your four-minute timeline by three and a
half seconds good job
okay uh again a reminder to my fellow
committee members i know some of you
have your hands raised you want to ask
questions i'm going to go to the next
two speakers and then we'll we'll open
it up for a question for everybody all
the speakers at that school
i'm next i'm going to go to uh
a speaker who supports the bill
from granite brock his name is skip
murphy and i know you asked for 10
minutes but i'm going to ask you mr
murphy to hold it to four minutes uh yo
chair i don't see a skip murphy
in the attendees
okay uh granite grock
i just rep promoted
okay
thank you
can you hear me
yes
okay again my name is skip murphy and i
spent nine years on my town's sb2 uh
budget committee uh was vice chair of
that committee
and for full disclosure i and
representative norm silber live in the
same town and we share the same concern
while
and i do have to address mr campos
testimony
where he said that there is no way to
change things the budgetary law does
allow for
a town or city to go to court and ask
for a special meeting if such an
emergency such as the pandemic needing
webcams
or any other kind of issue uh that might
arise in a particular town to seek and
appropriate additional money so the
nuance that i believe he left was that
well our hands are tight is is really
not so much
um
budget budget members spent hundreds of
hours going through the budgets at a
general ledger line item basis meeting
with
all the departments in all of the
tax spending
governing bodies be it the school board
the town
selectmen or water district or what have
you
spending a lot of time and what we found
uh norm and i
is that basically transparency was
erased because when we would say this is
not something that the town's
taxpayer money should be spent on
because of the way that the ms forms are
created and dealt with
that purpose and that's a singular uh
word that has very much meaning in the
process
that purpose if the voters approved to
do away with then the governing bodies
be they
town administrators finance directors
selectmen school board members what have
you basically override the
the will of the people and i think while
mr campo talked about it making his life
more difficult
i would urge this committee to think
about the voters who have said this is
how we wish to have our money spent
or not
and this also this process uh which i
had designed
not only says here's the line items that
cannot have monies expended against them
also gives a budget committee who then
proposes you know gives their budget to
the voters to approve can also
put more money into a general line item
which then tells the governing bodies
the voters have decided to spend more on
this so it works both ways as well
but it really
really is um in my mind a way for more
transparency because the voters say we
will do this we won't do that and i know
that in my town
we have caught uh the finance directors
or the governing bodies blithely
spending money on things that were not
approved and i think that's wrong from
the voters standpoint
we also see a lot of money being moved
around
such that things that were not approved
were then
purchased anyways and i think that's
that's a wrong thing
this is not a partisan matter this is
more of a technical fix
because of the the way that the ms forms
are have been written in our processes
representative silber said this is
simply trying to repair a gap in the
process because of the way those forms
have been done it's basically put a
small spreadsheet together here are the
general line item account numbers here's
the description for what that single
line purpose for spending was whether
it's for canine dog food or a brand new
fire engine or what have you
it keeps the governing bodies
uh from violating the will of the voters
and i think from my standpoint mr murphy
yes i'm done your time is up do you have
any final comments you want to make
i do well no i will leave it at that
pretty much norm uh representative norm
silver and i are on the same page on
that and i'm willing to address any
questions afterwards all right thank you
and hopefully you can stick around for a
few more minutes when we get to the
questions
next i'd like to recognize
uh the nhma is becky benvenuti
there yes i am here thank you mr chair
can you hear me okay yes i i'd like to
ask you to limit your your talk to less
than four minutes yes sir
so thank you mr chair and good morning
members of the committee for the record
my name is becky benvenuti and i'm the
government finance advisor for the new
hampshire municipal association and i'm
here today to speak in opposition to h.b
459 also cordell johnston of nhma has
submitted his own written testimony to
you this morning
hp 459 would control the use and the
creation of general ledger line items
for which exists for every major account
type and sub-accounts in the entire
chart of accounts
the chart of accounts is structured but
it's not a static financial
organizational tool it's dynamic and
over time the chart of accounts is
tailored and refined to continuously
reflect and report the details of
evolving municipal operations and
services and justin gave great examples
to that
this bill appears to target the use of
general ledger expense accounts but as
written this bill would prohibit the
creation of any new general ledger line
items which would include all asset
liability revenue and fund balance
accounts
in addition to expenses municipal
budgets include revenues liabilities and
operating fund transfers
many times when the budget is created
there are a few line items which show a
zero balance because of the importance
in keeping that account open or
to show the previous year's actual
expenditure that was made in that
account in the budget document for
comparison comparison
interestingly as was mentioned some
accounting software show these accounts
with a one dollar balance in order to
keep the account open
under this bill it appears that any
accounts with a one dollar balance
rather than a zero would be unaffected
so that you know that may be the
solution
the ability to set up new general ledger
line items throughout the year is
important to properly classify and
provide transparency and i'd just like
to give you a couple of examples over
the last few years laser jet printers
were originally provided by the state to
municipalities when municipalities were
required to become state municipal motor
vehicle agents and they were used to
prevent print all motor vehicle forms
registrations titles state forms when
those printers reached their life
expectancy and began failing
municipalities were informed the state
would not replace them
through no fault of their own
municipalities found themselves mid-year
having to purchase these printers when
they were not budgeted
under this bill this expense would
likely qualify as an unforeseen expense
and the creation of a new general july
item would be allowed however before
doing this calling a special meeting
would be necessary
to appropriate additional money to the
budget rather than the governing body
simply being able to create the new
general ledger line item transfer and
appropriation from an unexpended balance
of another approved appropriation to
fund this expenditure in order not to
increase the budget
another example of a real problem that
could come out of this is a municipality
passes the budget and they don't think
they're going to need a tan so they put
zero down for interest in in the tan
line item something happens and they
need a tan they end up either not being
able to get a tan which is a taxi
anticipation no i'm sorry i shouldn't
have just assumed that um they might not
be able to get the tan because they are
prohibited from paying the interest or
they have to do it anyways and get fined
and taken to court
there's no time to call a special
meeting and request that additional
money be appropriated for the budget
which is of course the reason for
needing the tan in the first place
also when the bill refers to calling a
special meeting in an emergency we are
assuming it's talking about a special
town meeting not meal or selectmen's or
a council meeting and that calling that
special meeting to appropriate money
would require court approval so the town
would have to a spend money on a lawyer
b spend money for the cost of the town
meeting and c then appropriate
appropriate additional money all instead
of just moving an appropriation from one
line to another which wouldn't cost
anything so for all these reasons we
respectfully request that you vote hb
459 inexpedient to legislate thank you
for your time
thank you i appreciate your testimony
and if you could stick around for the
next few minutes in case the members
have questions for you appreciate it
those of you i forgot to mention those
of you who have
testified and have a copy of your
testimony in written form
uh if you haven't submitted already
please submit it to our
committee clerk
representative john mcdonald you can do
that
via
emailing it directly to him or you can
email it to the entire committee if
you'd like so that would be helpful to
make sure the record is complete and
will help the committee as we go into
executive session on this bill
next monday
at this point i'd like to open it up to
the
uh the committee here
for questions i we have two raised hands
we have
representative porter and representative
stavis at least that would like to ask
questions let me start with a
distinguished
uh
thank you mr chair
i don't know who to direct this question
to
so i'm just going to put it out there
there are two issues that i'm
concerned about here
one
it seems that
individual members of a governing board
would be fined
and that there would be no recourse but
for them to pay it out of their own
pocket
if they were found guilty
um
that's my first concern and my second is
the cost of of holding a special meeting
so
the initial the question about the
individual
members being fined
would you think that this might have a
chilling effect on
volunteer
board members in small communities i
know in hillsboro we have a hard enough
time finding um people to run for office
if they knew they might be fined a
certain amount of money they have to pay
out of their own pocket plus the cost of
court proceedings that they might be
concerned about that and not want to run
and the second is calling a special
meeting costs money and how does that
fit into this um this budgeting
snafu that we have here representative
silva you want to take a stab at that
first
i'm unmuted now right
you kidding me okay
okay
uh i'll do it in reverse order uh the
concern about a special the expense of
having to call a special meeting
can normally be obviated by the fact
that most budgets
that are designed well
have a
contingency fund
number a line item for a contingency
fund for unanticipated expenditures
so that would cover for example the
replacement of uh printers that there
have exceeded their life expectancy now
only if the contingency fund was not
adequate would there be a necessity for
calling a special meeting
as far as the personal liability of the
uh the people in the governing body
as being a chilling effect on their
ability to function
uh it's the enforcement mechanism is
designed to be a chilling effect on
their
ability to ignore the will of the voters
as expressed in the budget so that if
they do not vote to transfer into a zero
line item that's been in approved budget
they have no liability but if they do
they know that they face the potential
for a citizen bringing an action to hold
them accountable for that so that's you
know that's the answer to those two
questions
okay
thank you representative i'll give you
uh mr campbell one minute to offer
mr chair all right mr campo you still
all right ron he's uh getting his
computer uh squared away we'll go to uh
can you hear me now
okay go ahead
perfect
so uh with the contingency fund i'm
assuming we're talking about rsa 3198a
uh the town of londonderry currently
doesn't have that because we looked at
it and it allows you to do one percent
of the budget
we've been giving back or we've been
underexpending by about under one
percent so we didn't think it was fair
to over tax our taxpayers
as for holding a special meeting i guess
that that is an option you're absolutely
right but timing becomes an issue
several times especially looking at a
pandemic where
we are you know we had trouble getting
a special me we had trouble
with the current elections for the
primary and general where now we're
having a special meeting closer to the
start of the pandemic and we're spending
additional taxpayer money to be able to
reappropriate taxpayer money to me it
just seems like we're spending a lot of
taxpayer money
to solve a problem that really fully
isn't there
and i understand the concern that's
there but in a case like this budgeting
one dollar across the board
to me that seems less transparent
next we have a question from
the committee representatives davis do
you have a question you'd like to
address anyone in particular
i do have a question and it's a kind of
in the weeds question and i think i'd
address this to representative silber
i'm looking at page two of the bill
um section
2 lines 24 through roughly 28 or 29
upon a good faith belief that a county
city town or other local government
entity has violated rsa 325d
any citizen of this state believing they
have been aggrieved so that's my
question
what is the burden
of evidence
on the aggrieved party here it seems to
me that this is a guilty until proved
innocent situation
um
okay if you can hear me okay uh i
believe i'll give you the lawyer-like
answer which is that it's like any other
civil action because this is a civil
matter and it is the greater weight or
the preponderance of the evidence it is
not
you go in there and the scale is evenly
balanced and the person claiming to be
agreed has to present evidence that a
violation has occurred the people who
are accused of doing that present
defense and if the scale tips one way or
the other that's the side that wins
it's the preponderance of the evidence
the greater weight of the evidence it's
a civil matter it's not it's not uh
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt and
it's it's not uh uh you know any
anything from the criminal law it's
basically a civil a civil matter and
it's the greater weight of the evidence
thank you
i'll tell you i'm ready to adjourn the
uh
the session on this uh house bill are
there any last
comments
that anyone would like to make
we're about five minutes past the uh
schedule to move to the next bill
uh but if someone on the committee has
some last comments they would like to
make or have a last question remember
this is our time to find out about the
bill not to not to argue or debate the
bill that we'll do that next week but uh
if any questions of those who testify
please raise your hand and and we'll
okay i'm gonna end the uh mr chair yeah
but mr silver raised his hand again i
don't know if he wanted to recognize him
okay representative silva you uh do you
want to speak some more on the bill
the only comment i would like to make is
that when i asked the legislative
services to draft the bill
i asked them to call the bill
what we have called it the people who
are the supporters of the bill call it
but they did not do so we call this the
bill
no means no bill
thank you
okay would you like to uh
for our executive session would you like
to submit an amendment to change the
name
that's not necessary thank you okay
all right uh for those of you on the
committee we will be hearing this bill
in executive session
i next move on to
house bill 586
so i'm going to ask
first i'm going to go to
representative alexander who is a
sponsor of the bill
and then i'm going to go to ben frost
in that order
and i'm going to ask both of you
to try to limit your time because we
have approximately 10 to 12 people who
want to talk to this bill and it's
going to be very difficult to get
everybody in
so i'm going to ask uh you to try to
limit your time to two minutes each
and if you need more time please ask for
it and uh we'll see where we are at that
point so we'll start with uh
uh hi mr chair can you hear me i can yes
okay great um for the record my name is
representative alexander i represent
hillsborough county district 6 which is
the town of goffstown
this bill has been
submitted
because we understand that housing and
affordable housing in the state is a
problem
this was a problem before kovid and i
think it still will be after
we got here because the governor
convened a housing task force in 2019
which aimed at solving the housing
crisis
through different um different avenues
but they came up with policy
recommendations so fast forward
those policy recommendations were
submitted last year
um through two different bills and i
believe the governor alluded to those
two bills in the letter that he sent
this morning to the committee to
in support of this bill
so this bill is a
this bill you've pretty much heard in
committee last year in municipal county
it was voted out of this committee um
in a positive way
let me be clear there's there's no
mandate in this bill and i want to go
through just a couple of the things that
this bill does to
solve the housing crisis in this state
so it directs office's strategic
initiative to develop a standard of
training materials to members of zoning
and planning boards free of charge
it um says that any fee on a development
applicant shall be published in a
location accessible to the public so
transparency of fees it streamlines the
approval and appeals process for
affordable housing development
it sets limits on how long the courts
that if if a decision was appealed by a
local planning or zoning board
um if a municipality allows increased
density or reduced lot size or expedited
approval of any procedural incentive for
housing with older persons the same
incentives must be offered for workforce
housing
it expands the definition of workforce
housing from 60 to 100 percent
of the area median income to 60 to 120
percent of the area minimum income
it allows municipalities to um
uh
allow for inclusionary zoning ordinances
um
that
that includes standards that don't
reduce the economic viability of
developments but do require or
but do allow for
um
i'm sorry let me go back
um so it it allows for inclusionary
zoning ordinances that include standards
that do not reduce the economic
viability of the development
and it establishes a housing champion
certification that's developed through
office of strategic initiatives and it
shall develop criteria for earning
certification
and shall develop the benefits for
municipalities
to earn the housing champion status so
we understand and we know this is an
issue for new hampshire
that's why it's needed i mean there's a
bunch of different organizations that
are here to testify in support of it
you saw earlier today in your inbox that
governor sununu
said this is a big priority for the
state um stay work play new hampshire is
supportive of the bill
they're people they're an organization
that's aimed at
getting more young people to stay work
and play in the state of new hampshire
business and industry new hampshire
housing action
we all recognize that housing before
kovid was the number one
problem facing the growth and future of
new hampshire so i look forward to
taking any questions i look forward to
you know as i mentioned on the last bill
those of you who have written testimony
i would ask you submit that to our
our clerk
john mcdonald or you can submit it to
the entire committee if you want using
uh
the email addresses on the
on the website
uh
i'm gonna next ask for ben frost just
please speak and and then i know you're
like an encyclopedia on this
particular topic so i know it's going to
hurt but i ask you to reduce your time
requested to three
minutes uh good morning mr chairman and
thank you for the opportunity to testify
before your committee in this pretty
weird format
um so my name is ben frost i'm the
managing director for policy and public
affairs at the new hampshire housing
finance authority and we strongly
support this legislation and thank
representative alexander and other
sponsors of the bill
for introducing it again this year
new hampshire housing supports this
because it will help to make housing
development um
a little smoother at the local level and
this is really the issue at hand here
and the reason why
uh the governor's task force and now the
governor is is uh in support of this
legislation and was last year with house
bill 1629 and 1632.
we all recognize i think that we've got
a problem with the housing supply in new
hampshire and that has is having an
impact on housing prices and rental
prices
and the ability of employers to find and
keep people
there's a great article in last week's
new hampshire business review a cover
story on selling new hampshire
abroad
and
there's a extensive quotes from the ceo
of fox biosciences in londonderry and
salem uh tom taylor talks about the
difficulty of
uh
getting and keeping people in his
company um because of in part because of
the housing supply this legislation does
a number of things as representative
alexander pointed out i'd like to focus
on a couple of them and i'm happy to
take any questions at any time mr
chairman
um first off the the provision on
inclusionary zoning this is on page two
of the bill
lines 14 through 26.
right now new hampshire law allows
municipalities to adopt inclusionary
zoning as a provision in their zoning
ordinances which is
as defined under current new hampshire
law a voluntary inducement to get
developers to build affordable housing
a number of jurisdictions uh
allow municipalities to mandate such
development and this would allow
municipalities both eat or either to do
voluntary inclusionary zoning or
mandatory inclusion or inclusionary
zoning with the caveat that if it is
mandatory it cannot be less economically
viable the development cannot be less
economically viable than it would be
without the inclusionary requirement and
this addresses one of the concerns
raised in a number of other
jurisdictions such as california vermont
uh florida and maryland where mandatory
inclusionary zoning is allowed but it
simply passes on the cost to the other
units in the development increasing
those prices uh this would require
essentially a municipality to do some
math if it were going to do mandatory
inclusionary zoning to figure out what
would make the project
equally viable um
another section this is also on page two
the requirement for written findings of
fact i do lots of land use law lectures
on behalf of the office of strategic
initiatives and the municipal
association and this is something i
always
say to the local board members you
really should be doing findings of fact
in every decision because it is your
instructions to we're reviewing court
this is why we made this decision
local boards are already required to do
a written notice of decision and this
could be embedded into that written
notice of decision
um there are a couple other changes here
i would say that uh on pages three
and four
um
mr frost this is the
darren dolan i would just ask that uh
you gotta wrap your comments in the next
30 seconds
um let me wrap it up then thank you mr
chairman for keeping a tight
time clock on this
um
the the provisions in this legislation
allow for a smoother process a more
transparent process one that is
will yield i think more
consistent outcomes at the local level
so that a developer going into the
process will have a better idea of what
the likely outcome is going to be and
i'll stop there
well thank you uh
just for uh our
administration here i'm next going to
recognize
a member of the public mr garuba
and then after him
i'm going to go to
carmen lorenz
just so if you uh
getting yourself coffee or whatever just
get ready you're going to be up soon
and again as a reminder if you have
written testimony please submit it to
the committee
okay uh
i just want to know that the audio is
working before i start here you sound
perfect okay great
so i appreciate the opportunity to
testify today and i just want to go
through uh some of the points that i saw
when i reviewed uh the language of this
bill
i'm here testifying today as a concerned
resident and a contributor to a local uh
to local government i spent the last
five years engrossed in local planning
matters and zba cases
i've taken the office of strategic
initiatives training for planning board
members and presented many arguments at
local zba and planning board meetings
my involvement has allowed me to see the
disadvantage that local residents are
presented with when opposing well-funded
and legally represented developers at a
local board
i'm not an expert by profession but my
experience provides me important insight
into this bill
i've reviewed the proposed language of
hb 586 and i find significant problems
with much of the language i've
identified 20 specific problems uh
problematic items and i've included
those in my written testimony i'm not
going to be able to touch on all them
today but i would appreciate if you go
back and review that
um today i'd like to highlight seven of
the most uh significant things that i
see in the bill
first uh we see allowing workforce
housing at the same the same density
benefits as housing for older persons
i'm just going to go through the list
and then i'll touch on the details the
second is allowing mandatory
requirements for the production of
workforce housing
adding time limits to planning and
zoning board actions
defining public use as
private land development
instantiating a mostly unelected board
with no representation from residents or
municipalities
uh requiring zoning ordinances that
enable
uh the planning board to waive local
requirements
and imposing costs on the butters just
to access the judicial system so i'll go
through these quickly so you can see
where i'm coming from on each one
so firstly is um
housing for older persons uh to receive
the same benefits at i'm sorry workforce
housing to receive the same benefits as
housing for older persons
this section overrides local zoning
ordinances which currently allow
retirement housing often at much greater
density than single-family homes
town residents carefully consider the
fiscal impacts
of allowing retirement homes at these
high densities
when they voted to include retirement
communities in their ordinance municipal
budgets are based on those calculations
it is well known that the most
the largest part of local taxes are
allotted to local schools and retirement
communities
retirement communities do not increase
those costs nearly as much as workforce
housing developments disagree but i know
you have a
long list that you're going through but
i'm going to ask you to try to wrap it
in about a minute
okay so
can we fix the feedback there yeah
now okay
so that's dramatically changing the um
ordinance that voters specifically chose
for their towns next i want to go on to
um
requiring the production of workforce
housing now this is a fundamental change
here because this allows ordinance
municipalities to require workforce
housing to be developed previously it
was incentivized requiring it is is
basically telling a property owner how
they would manage or what profits they
could make from their own private
property and i think that's a
problematic place to go from a state
from the state uh
point of view
imposing
time limits on both planning board and
zoning boards this one here is
is particularly problematic
uh the bill removes the ability of the
planning board and the select board to
extend the duration of the review
of a development proposal and the
problem here is that when development
proposals come in
they vary widely they they're each
individual dependent on the land that
they're developing
and many of them you could get
developments for one single family home
two three of them or you could get
developments for hundreds of of units at
a time
so
it is important that the planning board
has the flexibility to increase those
time limits because the amount of
engineering work
to review a large development of 50 100
units
it requires that extra time you cannot
it's not possible for someone to
carefully review all of the details in a
large proposal in the the fixed time
limits that this bill has taking those
abilities away from select boards
planning boards and zoning boards
is
guaranteed to result in poor decisions
due to lack of information and lack of
time to to do the right thing
is do you have enough time to be able to
uh stick around for the rest of the
meeting
i do
okay because i'm going to move on
to a couple of
of committee members who have questions
and i know you have more you'd like to
speak to so uh if we have some time at
the end we can uh come back to you again
okay i agree i very much appreciate that
thank you sir okay uh
we i'd like to
uh
representative imaginary do who's next
with your hands up do you have a
log of who's first
i i do on the committee mr chair uh
representative minju puti had her again
up first okay let's go to her first
thank you mr chair my question is not to
any speakers but
how will i know how many have signed up
uh
for
in support or
in opposition like the blue sheet if i
if you could uh
mention that that would be very helpful
thank you you have uh i have a list of
that we have
36 who signed up to support
11 have opposed
does that answer your question
all right uh
who else has that thank you
mr chair i have my hand up but i'm
really willing to yield my time to the
the others who have waited for vayne
okay could you did you put uh
patrick puti's hand down for me
and uh
representative maturi uh why don't you
go next and then we'll go to
representative lasalle's after you
thank you mr chair my question i guess
would be
to representative alexander i'm just
curious now that the housing appeals
board
is in full effect now that we are in the
second year of the budget
is there any conflict in the areas where
appeals need to go to the superior court
with what we now know is available
through the housing appeals board
um thank you representative for asking
that question um i would say this bill
just provides a different avenue for
appeal
and it also i mean it would
it would just
shorten the time that decisions need to
be made so i believe for the if i check
my notes
um
for the superior court it's 120 days and
for the supreme court it's 90 days but
it would just provide a different avenue
should should a developer or somebody
else choose that avenue
thank you secretary
representative lasalle
yes uh my name is rachel salas i'm a
member of the committee
and i am a co-sponsor of the bill i'm
from the small town of litchfield
and uh
i'm also a selectman in
the town of litchfield
we have a
very
i i i like to think of litchfield as
being
a very pleasant footballer town
uh
i also uh substitute teach in the local
high school campbell high school in
litchfield
one of the problems that i've identified
and is is well-known in the community
is the fact that
litchfield for
no fault of its own
uh has become a very affluent community
and
the
people who live there love it and it's
wonderful but there are very few
uh
people in the community that are outside
the
uh
what i would say the uh
standard
ethnicity
and uh
it's
the there
are very few opportunities for any sort
of diversity within the town uh of
litchfield we have a number of over 55
communities
in town like a dozen of them
i have always felt why couldn't we have
a
a number of under 35 communities that
would encourage young people
to
settle in our community right now
there's very little opportunity
for
anybody
uh
under that under the age of 35 to
purchase a home in this field because
the homes are so expensive
so
i am a proud supporter of this i
identify the fact
and i i know that i might take some heat
within the community for supporting this
but
i do
and i think it would uh move
our community as well as the state in
the right direction with respect to
workforce housing thank you mr chairman
thank you uh
for those of you who are needing to uh
testify i would ask that you think about
someone who may have testified before
you
and if you simply agree with what they
said i would suggest you to say i agree
with mr smith
or i oppose
the bill and agree with
uh mr jones
and
try to
truncate your testimony in that way
rather than just repeating what others
have said
i i asked for your indulgence to uh try
to help manage the time of this meeting
we're getting close to the end of the
the meeting time budget uh and i'm gonna
do what best i can
to
to uh to hear everybody next we're going
to hear from carmen lorenz member of the
public who represents the lakes region
community developers and after that
we're going to come back to the
committee
and recognize
uh representative gallagher
those are next few species
okay um
it's lorenz are you here
good morning mr chairman can you hear me
yes you're fine
thank you
uh
i work up in the lakes region our
organization lakes region community
developers is a non-profit
we develop affordable housing and
community facilities throughout the
region
and we are in support of this bill
one thing i would point out are you know
apart from your feelings on some of the
regulatory
aspects of the bill i want to make sure
everyone takes a look at some of the
financial incentives that are also
included um
there are a lot of communities that are
you know very forward thinking and i
would say welcoming of affordable
housing and they have a rather limited
toolbox to use and so
you know we we work with the city of
laconia and many other towns in our
region
several of whom are trying to help us
figure out how to build affordable
starter homes for first-time buyers and
there's virtually no toolbox for us to
use to do that right now in new
hampshire and i think one of the most
critical pieces of this bill from our
perspective has to do with the amending
the mending rsa
162-k which has to do with tax increment
financing districts
because enabling communities to use
tax increment financing for housing
development would be a game changer
often the reason why we cannot develop
affordable starter homes is because the
cost of the infrastructure
is just too much to get the water and
sewer to the site that we've
selected
and so we just simply can't make the
project work so i really think this
aspect of the bill in particular could
be really impactful for those
communities that have already decided
they want more affordable housing and
are ready and willing and even
helping us find sites this would give
them a really powerful new tool in their
toolbox that they could use to build
that so i'll leave it at that and thank
you for allowing me to speak good luck
with the rest of your hearing
thank you very much
uh representative gallagher do you have
a question
um yes i do i was just
wondering um
if i could
get a quick clarification on the
distinction between age-restricted
housing and workforce housing and
how they're handled in this bill from
some of the um drafters of this bill
if if mr frost is still on the line i'd
ask you to see if he could handle that
question
i'd be happy to mr chairman can you hear
me yes
great uh so representative gallagher
thanks for the question um the the these
are two different statutes that are in
play here
uh the elderly housing or age restricted
housing um is governed by rsa 354 a
colon 15 that is housing for older
persons
and it is an exception
to the
prohibition against age discrimination
so it allows for age discrimination
where a municipality or a
builder property owner is
is choosing to make a development a
property available for people who are
60 or 55 and older or 62 and older
depending upon the circumstances and
they vary slightly
so municipalities have used this to say
yes we'll give you a developer
additional density if you're going to do
age restriction which you are legally
allowed to do under that law and that is
so the state law matches um essentially
word for word federal law on on that
matter workforce housing is a new
hampshire statute in rsa 674 i think
it's
58 through
61 or 62
and was adopted in 2008 by the
legislature and it has a specific
definition
for what constitutes workforce housing
although that law says that every
municipality has to allow a reasonable
and realistic opportunity for the
development of workforce housing as
defined and it targets
property that is to be owned or to be
rented based upon the incomes of the
owner or the renter
and so
it the objective there is to um
one to codify the existing case law but
also to put some additional meat on the
bones of what the the courts were saying
was the municipal responsibility so
there are these two different statutes
uh and what uh house bill 56586
on page two uh lines six through
thirteen
um
it says if a municipality is allowing
additional density or other sorts of
inducements for property owners and
developers to do elderly housing
that's age restricted housing housing
for older persons as defined in 354 a15
then it must also allow the same sorts
of
bonuses density inducements for
i hope that's responsive to your
question thank you
next i'd like to
recognize representative porter and then
we're going to come back to the public
uh
mr penn case after representative porter
thank you mr chair um this question is
sort of for clarification and i'm going
to ask um ask it of representatives
alexander and ben frost
both of you have mentioned bills that
came through this committee um in the
past session
and but neither of you mentioned in your
comments that the bills that came
through
were significantly amended
um
by this committee prior to their passage
uh make sure that
i am right in saying that
when those bills were amended that's the
amended version of the bill that we are
seeing now number one and number two
concerns that were expressed in the
hearings then were addressed in that
amendment so i'm asking you if you can
tell me yes that is exactly right or no
i am wrong in that
um representative porter thanks for
asking the question i would just say
you're exactly right in that the
committee went through amended um
addressed a lot of the significant
changes or made significant changes that
address concerns from last year um the
reason why this bill was resubmitted is
because of last year due to covid
a lot of bills
had to
get itled um because of the state of
emergency so that's why this bill was
resubmitted but it's the it's almost a
carbon copy of what you voted out of
committee last year
thank you
thank you representative alexander and
next we're going to go to mr pinkasic
all right here i had to unmute yeah mine
will be very short mr chairman thank you
for allowing me the opportunity to speak
i live in hollis new hampshire erin and
pin kasich and i oppose the bill because
part of the reason we moved to hollis
was because we
uh we we value our property value
right and my concern is that high
density housing
in this town which is a farming
community
will reduce our property value
significantly and i don't think that's
fair to the to the residents of this
town who moved here
in anticipation of the town staying the
way it is
and i'll stop with that and yield back
my time to you
thank you mr penn casey
administratively let me uh
let you know that um
representative
piemonte arrived
a short time ago he had an additional
another appointment in the building and
he's now joined us
in the committee meeting
okay next uh and again
we're in what i'll call overtime right
now
and we're uh so that means those of you
who are arriving for hb uh 101 uh we're
going to start a little bit late on that
because of
586 going overtime so again those who
are called upon to speak i would ask
that you try your best to to just hit
the high points but like i said we are
now in an overtime situation
and i'm next going to go through
chris carley
uh who is neutral on the bill that would
just looking for the last name uh
c-a-r-l-e-y
is he not with us uh not by the last
name but that could be because it's
noted
as an organization
you see an organization listed for
representatives no just a member of the
public
okay let's move on if if he is online
please raise your hand and we will come
back to you
next i'm going to go to
margaret burns from the nhma
good morning chairman dolan members of
the committee i assume that you can hear
me i will be very brief when this
legislation was proposed last year there
were some provisions in it that we
opposed but as representative porter has
pointed out and the sponsors have
pointed out um this bill this year's
bill shows the includes the amendments
that were put in last year that we were
happy with that we worked on with
various stakeholders and so we are
officially neutral on the bill the bill
does have some provisions too that i
think will be helpful to municipalities
certainly we are always supportive of
additional training uh resources and
support so that concludes my testimony
happy to take any questions
thank you uh ms burns
uh next thing we're going to go to
uh harrison kansler
who's from the mount washington valley
housing coalition
and after that
we're going to go to taylor coswell
i hope i pronounced that right from the
from the state business and economic
affairs so
uh
harrison campbell you're up next
thank you very much can you hear me okay
yes you you're fine
thank you my name is harrison kansler
i'm the executive director of the mount
washington valley housing coalition
our office is located in conway new
hampshire we represent 11 communities in
northern carroll county
we i also work with two communities in
oxford county maine but that is not as
relevant i'll keep this as short as
possible i did send you all a written
testimony i would appreciate it if you
would take a look at it i tried to keep
that short as well
we we fully support this legislation um
you know it housing is a multi-faceted
issue facing our state and this brings
multiple tools to bear against that
issue
specifically for many of our communities
one of the concerns is that housing is
rapidly turning away from an issue of
just folks being able to get somewhere
to live
and is also rapidly turning into our
businesses not being able to keep their
doors open for lack of employees i've
spoken with many business owners in the
area who have
job offers have been turned down due to
lack of housing and that is not just you
know from restaurants and retail stores
that also comes from our hospital it
comes from our
our school administrative units um you
know we're having a hard time filling
positions um simply because there is
nowhere for people to live if they
should choose to take them um so you
know this is something that is starting
to become a
rapidly increasing economic issue in our
area and um and as a regard to that we
are fully in support of this bill thank
you
thank you
uh
next let's go to
um
[Music]
who writes you up for those guys
yes
well good
taylor caswell can you uh
from the uh business
economic affairs staff can you limit
your testimony to about a minute
sure mr chairman my name is taylor
castle i'm the commissioner of the
department of business and economic
affairs here in new hampshire
our department is charged with the
strategic development of our economy and
promoting the state from that standpoint
as well as our travel and tourism
industry
i just wanted to be very brief and let
everybody know i was the co-chair of the
group of the task force that originally
came up with a lot of these
provisions and i want to thank all of
the members of the legislature who are
bringing it back this year the big issue
for me really very clearly is workforce
is the top issue facing all of our
employers in the state of new hampshire
right now
pretty much across the board
and deeply connected with that is our
ability to continue to recruit workforce
and bring workforce to the state of new
hampshire and we are in a competition
with other states across the northeast
for this purpose
um we have seen over the last few months
that a few years excuse me
great progress in that area the karshi
school has done over unh has done their
regular net migration
numbers and we continue to show strong
progress in younger populations coming
to new hampshire but the thing that we
need to remember is that the connection
to housing and the ability to find
housing for people that are going to be
needed to continue to grow the economy
and do it in a responsible way that
allows communities to make their own
decisions as to how they want to proceed
under this under these important issues
is uh is really reflected in this
legislation and my department and i
personally strongly support this bill
and we stand ready to help the committee
work through any issues that they may
see here
but we really need to make the
connection between available and
affordable housing
to the further expansion of our economy
going forward so with that mr chairman i
will
stand back and let you proceed
thank you mr cadwell next i'm going to
go to alyssa margolin
from housing action new hampshire and
alyssa if i could ask you to try to
yes mr chairman thank you very much for
having me my name is alyssa marglin i
serve as director of housing action new
hampshire we're a statewide coalition of
80 organizations united around
affordable housing policy
just the highlights of my testimony
as
representative porter pointed out
the house bill 586 is really the result
of years of evaluation discussions and
compromise those of you who were part of
this committee last year of course
worked on the amendments for house bills
1629 1632 so what you have
um as a result of those discussion
and as you know commissioner caswell
just noted the governor's housing task
force
pulled a lot of these proposals together
but these proposals have been also part
of prior study committees and
commissions such as
the study commission on barriers to
housing development housing we need
stakeholder recommendations the sb-43
commission on land density and many
others the list goes on
in many ways we could call this toolbox
build the low hanging fruit proposals
as um
developer carmen lorenz noted you know
opening up economic development programs
like tiffin 79e to affordable housing
development
just makes sense
and then there's the issue of there's an
unquestionable need the lack of
affordable housing has been called a
crisis by new hampshire business
magazine new hampshire business review
as well as other business publications
it's a high priority for workforce
recruitment and retention and as we have
learned important social determinant of
our collective public health so uh we
urge you to move uh this bill along in
the process and thank you for your
service during this challenging time
thank you for your testimony
uh next we'll hear from
sarah holland from the new hampshire
good morning can you hear me fine yes
you can hear fine thank you thank you
chairman my name is sarah holland i'm
the broker owner of sarah holland and
company located in plymouth i'm also the
vice chair of the new hampshire
association of realtors public policy
committee
i'm here on behalf of the 7 000 realtors
across the state asking for you to
support hp 586. i know it's hard to
overstate the need for this legislation
housing inventory across the state is at
a historic low and we don't think people
recognize just how dire the situation
has become so i'm going to share some
statistics just five years ago in
january of 2016 new hampshire had over 7
500 residential properties for sale
today there are fewer than 1500 homes
for sale across the state
that's an 80 drop in inventory
in just five years
a healthy level of inventory in the
residential market is usually considered
to have four to five months of supply
this means that if all properties on the
market currently were to sell and
nothing new came on the market those
homes would be completely sold out in
four to five months
as of december 2020 just a couple months
ago our inventory is a little over three
weeks
three weeks and everything would be gone
this means new hampshire families are
being priced out of the market it's
simply supply and demand um supply is so
low in demand so high that prices are
absolutely skyrocketing the median sale
price for a single family home is 350
dollars
five years ago the median sale price was
two hundred and thirty thousand dollars
that's a fifty two percent increase in
just five years
the condo market's even worse with
prices doubling in just the past seven
years and in some instances the prices
are increasing by 16 from sale to sale
hb 586 is not a silver bullet but it's
an important step in the right direction
realtors can attest that the frustration
our clients are experiencing is very
real the tears many new hampshire
residents shed as they are outbid time
and again by people just as desperate to
find housing is all too real and
heartbreaking
we all need to recognize the developable
you try to wrap about 30 seconds
sure
developable land in new hampshire is
finite if we allow development for over
55 housing that means less opportunity
for young workers so we need to keep our
economy moving forward
everyone plays a role in this so um
the various requirements contained in hb
586 are modest practical and common
sense and we want to thank the sponsors
for bringing this bill forward and we
strongly encourage the legislature to
support hb 586 thank you mr chair thank
you and again as a reminder for those
who are speaking but don't feel like
they've got all the time they wanted to
get their testimony and if you provide
written testimony
the committee will read it we don't
accept this bill until next monday so we
have a week to read it and
if you submit it we will get it so thank
you
uh our next speaker
will be will stewart
from the stay work plain new hampshire
organization
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee um i am will stewart executive
director of stay work play and as
representative alexander mentioned we
are a statewide nonprofit whose mission
is to attract and retain more young
people here in the granite state and
that's uh very much a necessity as we
are the second oldest state in the
country with one of the lowest
unemployment rates even during the time
of covid and one of the biggest out
migration rates of uh of high school
graduates seeking a four-year degree so
long story short we need all the people
we can get in general all the young
people in particular
we did a big data collection about three
years ago
asking young people in new hampshire
what's what are the reasons you might
leave the number one reason that came
back that said that they might leave new
hampshire this is people between the
ages of 20 and 40 said lack of housing
that's affordable both on the rental end
of the uh spectrum and home ownership as
well we heard this again last year as we
went around the state as part of our
policy and pint series to nine regions
all across the state and again the
number one thing we heard was it's too
expensive to live here um especially you
know and leading uh cause being the cost
of housing and for young people of
course this you know it's expensive for
everybody but it's especially expensive
for the young people we need because a
you know they're younger earlier in
their careers making less money as you
might expect often we have one of the
als also too we have one of the highest
student debt loads um average in the
country
so it's kind of a perfect storm and so
we are in full support of this bill and
looking at any ways to reduce housing
costs in new hampshire thank you
thank you for your testimony
uh we have a couple of hands that are
raised from
people who have joined a meeting that
have not asked to speak prior to the
meeting so
let's try uh representative imaginary
thank you very much chairman dolan can
you hear me yes go right ahead
thank you very much i'll be very brief
because i i recognize that uh we are
running over um thank you so much for
the opportunity to speak my name is doug
marino um i live in strab new hampshire
i work for an organization called 603
forward whose goal is to help attract
and retain young people to new hampshire
although i am speaking on behalf of
myself
for this bill uh in strong support um i
won't repeat um anything that's already
been said um i have um you know a lot of
friends from high school and college
who've left the state who would have
loved to have
built a career and family here but
simply couldn't afford it and i believe
that house bill 586 is a step in the
right direction and i thank you so much
for your time today and for your
diligent work on this well thank you for
your testimony next we'll hear from mark
fujii
good morning uh thank you for allowing
me to speak i'll just be brief
um i support mandy i'm a plenty
consultant in the state
i haven't done a lot of work on
workforce housing and there's one
particular section
that i'm very concerned about uh in this
bill i support the issue of workforce
housing it's very vital to our economy
but section seven would amend the
workforce housing statute and increase
the wage the income criteria to 120
percent of area median income
this will drastically impact the
affordability of housing in the state in
a negative way for example right now in
nashua
um the income ratio is at 100 is 113 000
which means that an affordable home is
394 000
if we increase that to 120
income will increase to 136 000 and
obviously the price point of a home will
increase i don't see how
going to 120 is going to help our
economy um i urge the committee to amend
this back to 100 and not change that
provision thank you very much
thank you for your testimony and last
thank you very much uh mr chairman i
trust
thank you i trust you can hear me mr
chairman we hear you fine okay very good
um i'm alan reeds of plainfield i have
cut my remarks down to less than a
minute i'm a long time employee of the
hanover co-op new hampshire's largest
independent grocery store i want to
express our support for hb 586. our
homegrown business was founded in 1936.
it's an 85 million dollar business today
nothing happens without our 350
employees
in this time of covid that's kept the
food flowing to local residents the lack
of affordable housing ranks among our
biggest concerns and business threats
our business is doing everything it can
to help employees with health care
training an average starting wage of
fourteen dollars an hour but nothing no
business can tackle this housing issue
alone
if our essential workers who are truly
essential community members can afford
to own or rent a home in new hampshire
every other aspect of living here gets a
boost job creation health care day care
education transportation fill in the
blank it all works better with an
affordable place to live
thank you for the opportunity to share
these remarks i sincerely appreciate
thank you mr reed and with that i'm
going to conclude
the hearing
on hb 586.
hp 586 representative dolan you do have
one other person that is on the list
it's molly lund owen
did she drop off is she on she's on
she's not okay please uh please go ahead
we have one more speaker and if you can
keep it down to a minute i would
she dropped off my list over here do you
ever
as soon as soon as oh there she is again
when she disappeared that's yours again
can you hear me this is molly yeah we
can hear you fine now excellent thank
you so much mr chairman um good morning
committee members this is molly alan
owen i'm executive director of 603
forward we help we advocate on behalf of
working age adults in new hampshire
but i'm speaking today mostly on from
personal experience
every person i talk to in my line of
work as well as a member of the local
young professionals committee in
manchester mentions the cost and
availability of housing as their number
one
issue of importance whenever we speak
from personal experience i'm the i'm a
member of the planning board in
manchester i was just appointed as an
alternate and i'm fortunate we have a
staff appointing staff in manchester
that gave me a full
binder of information but i know it's a
huge barrier to entry for young people
to
join these planning and zoning boards
the education and learning more about
these laws it's a barrier to entry so i
support this bill because of the the
training component and also because my
husband and i have a nine month old and
we rent we've saved up enough money for
a down payment but there is nothing
available so we are renting for the
disabled future just because there's
almost no housing
available um
and i know i'm not the only one facing
that challenge so thank you for being
here i'll submit written testimony and
i'm i'm thankful for everyone's
attention this morning
well thank you so much for your
testimony i'm glad we could squeeze it
in
okay uh let's end the uh
this hearing uh for those of you who are
keeping track of the calendar as i
mentioned earlier we will take this bill
this is what we call one of our early
bills because it has to go to another
committee
uh probably one of the finance
committees for consideration of costs
uh and then uh and then it uh
we'll head over to uh
be considered by the entire house
so uh
we will be taking this still into
executive session
on the afternoon of the eighth
a week from today
all right uh we are a little bit behind
so we're going to move right on to uh
hearing for hb
which has to do with how we close a
county book of records
representative mcdonald did you do you
want to start with this or do you want
to uh
yeah you want to have uh
representative abrami uh introduce it
uh
well i'm sorry that he is not the first
one
i have an issue
good morning chairman members of the
discipline county government it is our
place to give you today
did you know my name is john mcdonald i
am from cal county district six
which consists of the community of
workforce
i'm here to introduce to the committee
healthcare 101 with with a proposed
amendment
please still come to the request of some
of my fellow colleagues from the
california delegation
this still identifies a period of time
45 days following the end of this period
ninja tommy has disclosed the book for
that period
and even if the county has not done that
they may request an extension from the
commissioner of the department of
government
and i believe you should have a copy of
uh
the particularity 28 colon 3d
telling the artist for this uh build
that uh
we drop into
uh
the amendment i'd like to present is to
change the requirement from
yeah i could forget that one
again and could you make sure a copy
was that due to my mistake earlier or do
you have something you'd like to add
representative
representative romney are you with us
yes i'm here
there he is okay we got you now are we
on uh are we on um
your volume is very low so maybe you
could speak a little closer to the mic
yeah but we'll do
okay uh
thank you can you hear me now
yes okay uh
uh for the record uh state rep pat
abrami rockham 19
stratham
um
on uh representative romney uh we're
still a little behind schedule still on
101. i'll come back to you in just a few
minutes
for you okay that's what i thought i was
wondering why you called me
am i on the other bill by the chance or
something raised on the uh electronic uh
screen in front of me
oh so so now i want to turn for for hp
101 i want to turn to the committee to
see if anybody has questions
uh for
on this bill and especially for
representative mcdonald that introduced
it
yes let me see i see your hand up for
uh representative porter
thank you mr chair uh representative
mcdonald it was a little hard for me to
hear you um and i wasn't sure have you
sent uh around to us
the the amendment you you were offering
an amendment to the bill
did you send that amendment to us
uh i
thank the question for the report i
believe i emailed a copy of it to
uh
the chairman and also to uh miss
goalie uh but i'll definitely double
check and send that out if that's not
the case
i certainly will have this
representative reporter we certainly
have this available to us before we
uh vote to execute next week okay and
that was the only change in the in the
amendment
seeing none but there's one more hand
please i'm sorry mr chair for our
representative
representative power you're up
thank you mr chairman the question that
i have um on this bill is
um
i understand that there's an amendment
changing the the days um to close the
books from 30 to 45. my question is
historically
i'm assuming that counties typically do
not take longer than 45 days to close
uh thank you
representative i can't talk about
uh other counties in carroll county uh
at this present time one of the reason
this bill was was
written was
there's no specific time limit that
counties have to close their their books
and we've had problems in county where
uh we're just finishing up our 2019
uh audit
and we wanted to put a little pressure
on
when some of the counties get these
things done in a timely fashion and if
there's a problem
they can go to uh
uh d-a-e-r and ashford extension and the
seeing none uh as representative porter
question there is an amendment to this
to this bill and
you will be provided a copy of that
amendment to consider at the executive
session next week whether or not you
want to adopt that amendment or not
okay with that i'm going to close the
the session
on hb
and move to hb 164
which is relatively acquisition scale or
demolition of municipal land or
buildings
and
i'd like to bring up representative
arami the prime sponsor to speak to the
bill
focus closer to the mic a little bit
yeah i know thank you
appreciate that um uh again for the
record state rep pattern rockingham 19
stratum
i'm here to introduce house bill 164.
this pill uh was house bill 1104 last
year
it passed this committee and anonymously
it passed the floor on consent calendar
and died to death with hundreds of other
bills in the senate
the bill just wasn't taken up in the
senate last year along with hundreds of
other bills
so basically this is the house position
what it does it makes a minor change
to rsa 41 colon 14-a
the last time this chapter was updated
was back in in 2008
so what the chapter does if a town
if a tom adapts what this provision
currently says
that the select board shall have the
authority to acquire or sell land
building or both however they first must
submit
any such proposal of acquisition or sale
to the planning board
or the conservation commission
which they were only have the ability to
review and comment to back to the select
board on
what happens next is that
there are two public hearings
must be held
before a vote now during that period
if if there are 50 signatures from
voters it can become a warrant article
as well
and again this is an enabling
legislation the town has to adopt this
provision
okay and this is i'm talking about
current law now
so what does the bill do many times have
adopted this provision
uh
to rsa
oops rsa
uh uh
uh 41 11-a is the controlling statute
if they don't excuse me if they don't
adopt this provision the controlling
yes
okay
in check in checking with the municipal
it is not clear how many towns have
adopted this this
provision uh but i have i did by the way
i did communicate with the uh the
municipal association this year i just
communicated over the weekend and they
they they have no position on the bill
just as they did last last
year
so
so what what does this bill do it makes
two changes to rsa 41 14-8
it adds to demolition or disposal of
buildings
to acquire or sell land or buildings
to uh
because
why building what the reason why is that
buildings can be gotten rid of in many
ways that are not selling they can be
torn down
what it does is it adds to the provision
in addition to the planning board and
the conservation commission having to
say
it adds
the uh the uh
it adds only
uh the conservation commission
to that list
and when the bill was in
committee last year uh representative i
see i see you there representative
gilman from exeter
she added in committee an amendment
to include
the historic districts as well
so that's what you see in this bill
which is the bill that the bill you see
informing you in front of you hasn't
changed that is the bill that passed on
the house floor last year
so that's what it does
uh
david canada from stratham uh
former chair of the select board for
many years
and former chair of the heritage
commission i know is
is uh willing to testify in the spell
and they should be on the line
i'll take any questions but i i think
mr canada
can give you some insights being a
former select board member as well as a
heritage commission member as well but
i'm willing to take questions mr chair
thank you representative and
representative gilman you got anything
you'd like to add to the
testimony we just heard
i think representative
bromley did the uh did the job i would
just like to add there are a few
examples of uh municipal buildings that
have been threatened or actually have
lost to demolition um
historic and you know historic buildings
that uh show the heritage of the
community and how it's grown over time
so this bill is is just a way to protect
that and give the public the opportunity
to say okay
we don't need to keep this or no i want
to keep this
okay thank you i this is a bill that i
have indications from those
testifying or wanting to testify there
is no opposition to this bill
uh among representatives or the public
so i'm considering heading towards and
executing this bill when we're done with
the testimony unless i hear opposition
so with that in mind next i'm going to
recognize
good morning again margaret burns with
nhma i will be brief as representative
obrami said we are neutral on the bill
and we have communicated with him on the
language it does appear to clarify the
question of the select board's authority
to demolish or otherwise dispose of
buildings under 4114a
um and so we have no issues with the
language and have no position on the
bill thank you happy to take any
questions
thank you uh the last person to testify
that is on my list is david canada he's
a member of the public and he supports
chair i do not see a david kennedy
okay yes and
if he shows up please let me know in
place of mr canada we'll go to jennifer
goodman
good morning you can hear me okay yes
perfectly i'm jennifer goodman the
executive director of the new hampshire
preservation alliance which is the
non-profit historic preservation
organization
help about 100 community projects every
year lots of homeowners property owners
and have worked with legislators some of
you i'm kind of filling the toolbox and
removing
uh obstacles to historic preservation
and community development over the years
and um we hope you'll um send this
through again uh it feels like a good
housekeeping bill that
and appreciate the sponsor's work on
this
um municipalities are um pulled in a
million direct directions very busy and
these important changes feel like
they'll really add
a layer of predictability to acquisition
and disposition processes
and from a stroke preservation and
community development perspective
like representative gilman mentioned i
think helped to prevent unnecessary
losses in our communities that um have
big potentials so thank you very much
for the time thank you for your
testimony and uh i take it uh mr
candidate was not able to uh
get through you not see mr canada mr
chair okay any last uh questions from
the committee or from the public i'm i'm
considering taking this right to
executive session mr chair you have one
hand raised in uh on zoom and one hand
raised in the meeting
okay
it seems that
we are receiving the bills for the
correction of selectmen men
and i will bring it to line 24 of the
bill
and there is not a correction made
uh on
the word selectmen instead of select
through it and i don't know if the
person
uh
considering the bill wants to change
that to select board
in addition
and there's a required let's ask
representative of romney for
representative gilman do you do you feel
that that needs an amendment to uh
to line up the language there that was
that was a suggestion thank you mr chair
that was a suggestion that i made to
representative brownie because people
because towns are moving on to select
board instead of select men
um but uh i would
you know i no i have no objection to
leaving it as it is uh just
how many do you ever comment on that did
you want me to comment uh chair
representative romney
right ahead
so yeah uh in most places we caught that
and we do have select board
uh
i think the way it works is that once
the bill passes we could probably fix it
over in the senate
or
they'll they'll catch it because a lot
of these current statutes
that have selectable
select
uh uh selectmen
have are automatically being changed
select board it's my understanding
right the other the other place to uh
change it would be when it goes to the
full house you can offer an amendment at
that point as well
right
right we have a comment from
representative chip
uh mr chair if we're correcting things
and if you go to line four there's a
selection in console
so uh you might want to consider
changing that also
okay did you did uh representative
romney did you hear that one as well
you might have to unmute yourself
um mr chair might i note that it it
seems to have been caught every place
else
selectmen was changed to select board it
seems to be it's those only those two
spots
right
of the bill
well
i'd like to hear from the committee
would you be okay
with
accepting it with these
uh
minor errors to execute now or would you
rather wait for an amendment
and then we can execute it next week
but uh any uh any comment from the
committee on that either one way or the
other
if you have a comment just raise your
hand and uh we'll recognize you
representative
uh mr pooney you have your hand up
yes thank you mr chair my
question is not in regards to the
wording
this is to the prime sponsor was any
consideration paid attention which i'm
really glad to see that historic
preservation
and uh restoration commission is also in
support of this there is a process of
getting approval from historic
resources natural and historic resources
that timeline can be as long as
18 to 24 months uh in new hampshire
there is no precedence in terms of how
long it takes is there any
uh attention paid to that to restore
old building before it's considered for
demolition
i'll i'll admit that i'm not an expert
in this area
so i i can't really uh answer that
question i wish i could
um maybe someone on this committee knows
better than i about that
this uh just to follow up uh mr chair
this is really good in terms of
um
reducing the
carbon footprint in terms of net zero so
the process if there is an incentive the
process
and i think if jennifer goodman can
okay um
we have uh
representative mayman has her hand up
idiot my hand is up and the carpenters
are loud sorry i was just going to say
that in terms of the language i'd be
comfortable passing it on
and catch those language issues
in the senate i think that's safe to do
and i think there's an advantage to go
ahead and finishing this up today
thank you
representative trillan you have your
hand up thank you mr chair i appreciate
it very much and sorry i just butted in
earlier
um
two things one i'm in favor of passing
it with these two minor changes that we
can attack attack and change in the
senate and second in regards to
representative mind deputy's comment in
regards to how long do buildings hang
around
dover is a success story as far as sax
is concerned we have just signed a deal
with a local developer mr chinberg and
we will be
refurbishing and adding on to and
opening up our old county courthouse
which is on first and second street in
dover and that thing has been empty
forever and it's a gorgeous old dover
building so
it's almost like never say never keep
hoping keep waiting keep trying to find
the right partnership because we've got
it here thanks
thank you
representative clee you have your hand
done
thank you mr chairman um i i think i
just want to say ditto as far as the um
voting today and doing the cleanup at
another point either on the floor or in
the senate i i think it would be good
just to
finish up this bill thank you
okay uh
we have jennifer goodman with their
handouts
oh excuse me i only did that in case
there was a direct question coming back
to me about the timing
okay
uh
yes mr chairman thank you can you hear
me all right yes perfectly
um i just wondered if you are making
amendments to this
to this bill whether it would be
possible to
tie this bill to the bill that's in
house education having a hearing
tomorrow
allowing
municipal school buildings
to be offered as a writer first refusal
to charter schools
and whether demolition of any municipal
buildings would also
qualify
and be something that could be offered
in your list of
offerings to various organizations
whether it would be offered to the
department of education for the charter
school coordinator
well while i am
not an expert i i do uh
understand that in the house we
typically have bills that deal with
single issues whereas the senate is more
apt to have what they call omnibus type
bills that will
clump together many issues under a
single bill so if if you were thinking
that this bill and a bill in another
committee could be combined that makes
sense
it would be my uh thought that that
would that would be better accomplished
in the senate side
thank you mr chair um what i was
referring to is
this would this would work in
conjunction with the other bill
the other bill is just merely talking
about
unused
school buildings this would be
expanding it to unused
municipal buildings of any kind
so
they they actually do the same thing
yeah i believe uh
the intent and i'm ready to be
contradicted by
representative romney or representative
gilman i think the intent is
municipal buildings would it would also
include
uh school buildings as well
that would be terrific if that's
included in in there i just didn't see
uh charter schools listed
along with all of the other
um
opportunities uh going to the historical
commission and things like that um
if if charter schools were included in
that listing that would be um then it
would work
symbiotically with the the bill in the
house
okay any any other comments thank you
for your testimony any other comments or
questions yes representative gilman has
her hand up
yes i just wanted to respond to the last
commentator i i think under the under
this bill um
the word disposition
and that's it thank you mr chair
so i'm uh i'm still in the ultimate
representative
representative porter yes please uh
please continue
thank you mr chair i'm just trying to
remember back to the testimony that we
heard last year when we heard this bill
and my understanding was
this was um
brought forward by a community who had
lost a lovely building um
it was a beautiful building and and
someone had donated to the town and
before anybody could really do anything
about it it was destroyed or sold or
whatever the thing was so i think that
that was the impetus between between
behind this particular bill i might be
wrong and representative uh gilman and
representative abrami might
just you know dissuade you of what i'm
saying but i think that was the goal of
this bill was to preserve these
buildings or give the community the
chance to preserve these buildings
before
they were just automatically
destroyed
thank you representative gilman
yes i just wanted to uh back uh to
respond to representative porter that
indeed that was the purpose of of this
bill but also
to add we wanted to add in the historic
district commission and the heritage
commission because that aspect of a
building wasn't included and also the
conservation commission
doesn't at least in my town doesn't deal
with buildings at all or just one um and
the city and the planning board
doesn't
consider
that kind of
that kind of aspect i guess okay thank
you uh just before i we go on to uh to
executives as i still i'm still inclined
to accept this now
uh i think it'll go pretty fast and uh
that will lighten our load next
monday afternoon
from a committee standpoint but i wanted
to mention a couple of administrative
things that i may have admitted earlier
if members of the committee
were present in the llb need to take a
bathroom break
or take an urgent telephone call outside
the hallway
uh you just do that on your own you
don't need to ask my permission you just
use your own judgment
but there is a there is a big but with
that if we are indeed
asking a question or a question is put
forth an executive session and that
happens and you're out of the room when
you return you will not be allowed to
vote
on that particular question
so uh you need your judgment
especially during hearings but
especially be careful in executive
sessions that you don't exit the room
and then uh find yourself being excluded
from a vote if if we're calling the
question while you're out
and that's just my administrative note
sir
uh
representative florida you have one more
question
okay
i'm not sure mr chair if representative
romney has a question
mr uh representative obama you have your
hand up on our software do you want to
make another comment
i i think i'm i'm all set thank you
all right at this point i'd like to
on bill 8164 and move to executive
session
and i'd like to represent representative
uh thank you mr chairman uh i would move
lots of chaos on house bills
164 relative to the acquisition sale or
demolition municipal land mobility thank
yeah we have a second
uh and i'm sorry representative let's
all right at this point
we're going to take a roll call vote
on ought to pass please indicate your
mr clark
yesterday please call a roll call
representative
yes
representative guthrie yes
representative here
yes
representative power
representative gallagher
yes
representative majority
representative
yes
yes go ahead
um i'm not seeing representative ayers
handsome face on my screen
yes
i'm wondering if um
my understanding was when votes are
taken we have to be visible so i'm just
asking if that is in fact the case yes
thank you for that comment and uh
we're going to ask that
representative make sure that he has his
video working and i'm going to ask you
yes
thank you
thank you for putting up with that
that's a that is uh
that is a rule that we have
uh
if you aren't on camera
uh you are not allowed to vote and that
normally would pertain to those folks
who are calling in on a phone that has
no video like if you're on a car phone
or whatever so
but here's a case we just ran across
with representative here that uh
i'm glad we could we could fix that so
we have your registered vote now thank
you so much representative
mr chairman yes uh do you want this to
go on the consent calendar yes without
objection we'll place
and what's the final vote charlie uh 19
to 0. 19-0 thank you very much mr clerk
all right uh we're going to end that uh
executive session and now open a hearing
on house bill
445.
the uh
i'd like to recognize first
uh
representative marsh
mayor report that nazi representatives
march yet
the dc representative uh cordelli who i
believe is the prime sponsor
without if you don't object i'll allow
him to speak yes please representative
thank you i am the prime sponsor of
hb445
and uh i represent tuftonboro
moultonborough on sandwich in the
beautiful lakes region
and as some of you might know
carroll county has been through
a difficult period
in
the not distant past
with running a deficit not doing
financial audits
um mention of bankruptcy and uh
some some difficult times but we are
coming out of it we are on
uh a better path uh we've turned the
curve
and um we are all very hopeful and the
delegation and commissioners are working
together uh quite well at this point
uh this bill
uh deals with uh competitive bidding
um and there's a
back story to the drafting of this bill
but
it came out of legislative services with
a
prior bill on the same subject that i
had
submitted
uh several years ago during this uh dark
period
in our uh recent past
i believe you have an amendment um
i mailed it to the committee last night
and i think
administrative services was to provide
copies this morning to anyone in person
um it is amendment uh
0171 h
and this
amendment replaces the entire bill
and it very simply
adds
carroll county to the existing statute
28 a
e
for hillsborough county
and we would follow the same
purchasing
requirements
laid out in the statute by hillsborough
county
we have been in contact with all the
hillsborough representatives and i have
uh
correspondence from the delegation chair
and vice chair from hillsborough
that they have
no objection
and see no problem with carroll county
being added to their statue
i think that the
statute
evidently has worked well for them
uh it's been in place for uh a number of
years
and uh i think it would be very
reasonable way to proceed for carroll
county
and um with that i'm i'm glad to answer
any questions
thank you representative before we go to
questions is there anybody else who
being done and seeing uh no uh hands
raises anybody did just pop up mr chair
i'm sorry okay gary
thank you very much uh chairman uh for
the record my name's gary abbott
i'm the executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire
i will tell you that i ran this
legislation before i represent
commercial and industrial contractors
and subcontractors
and we only raised the concern
one of the concerns we had was having
multiple statutes for different counties
with different competitive bidding it
sounded like the amendment that was just
proposed kind of addresses that concern
one of the things that we were concerned
about is having multiple county
competitive bidding language in the
state statutes
cities and towns as far as i know do not
do this
and it just
i worked long and hard many years ago
on construction building codes and all
of those things
not to have individual codes in the
statutes but having a building code
review board that has the
uh power outside of it and was just a
concern that was raised with the
contractors was we ought to be careful
as to writing separate we have
competitive bidding requirements in the
statutes for the state
but as we develop
the concern was if we started to do it
for counties and then are we going to do
it for cities and towns i would just
leave that with the committee it's
completely up to your committee and the
legislature to decide that but i thought
we would give that additional input
sounds like the amendment's going to
follow another statute of the
hillsborough county and and that sounds
like a good plan if counties had a
standard statute that addressed it in
one place that makes a lot of sense i
would end there and thank you for
letting me have the opportunity to speak
well thank you for giving us your
testimony if you have anything you'd
like to submit in writing please do
any other questions uh we see your hand
up from representative power
thank you mr chairman for taking my
question my question um pertains to the
amendment the amendment that's proposed
ties both the counties of hillsborough
and carroll together in the statute
and um i guess my concern is that due to
the fact that these counties are
dissimilar in many ways is it prudent
to um
you know have this
statute combined
the the concern being that if um
one of the counties wanted to make a
change then it affects
the other county that's um listed in the
statute
well good question let me let me bounce
it back to representative fordelli is
the other counties combined or did did
you just
copy and paste language from one county
to the other document
the statute
refers to hillsboro hillsborough county
and in the amendment we just add carroll
county to that so the
title of the
paragraph leads competitive bidding
hillsborough and carroll counties
so the same
uh provisions apply to both counties um
i think that the provisions
are
uh quite uh reasonable and standard in
uh other places that uh i have been and
worked in
so i don't think that
any differences between our counties uh
will have a
significant impact at all
but i appreciate the
question okay thank you anything else
okay any other questions in the
committee
[Music]
anybody else from the public who might
uh
have not notified us in advance they
want to speak but have decided now that
please raise your hand if you're if
you're calling on the phone only
hey we don't have any uh
any additional comments
counting us now on the phone with raise
their hand okay
do we know who that is i do not know who
that is okay who has their hand raised
from carroll county
hi um on behalf of commissioner terry
mccarthy who stepped out of the room
to take a phone call this is melissa
siemens the executive coordinator for
the board of commissioners um i believe
okay
seaman
yes
on behalf of commissioner terry mccarthy
she asked that i left
you know that the carroll county
commissioners are opposed to hb 445
and
had passed a statement to me to read
the short argument is that this bill
even the amendment
infringes on the executive branch's
authority to manage the county pursuant
to its obligations
the board of commissioners is
responsible for all county departments
and exercise budgetary oversight of all
county finances
other responsibilities include the
management of county buildings and land
and personnel authority to permanently
hire discipline and discharge a county
employee
or out solely the responsibility of the
county commissioners unless otherwise
provided for
the statement goes on to note articles
of the new hampshire constitution
including article number 37 the
separation of powers
usurping the authority of the executive
the statement also references article 39
and notes the county convention is the
legislative branch of government and the
powers of the convention are laid out by
law and constitution
and
which
clearly
delineates the powers of the delegation
the commissioners are tasked with all
necessary acts relating to the concerns
of the county
and that is what i have handed to me in
this statement at this moment
thank you
seaman i would ask that if you could
take that what you just read and submit
it to the committee at the very least
submit it to our clerk so we can put it
i will certainly do that
thank you
all right
yes just a quick question mr chair thank
you for taking my question how many
uh signed up in a position or in support
on the blue shield thank you yeah we
have four in support and one in
opposition
and those are the people who signed up
before
and i would say that
in addition to that we've had one
testify and and supported two in
opposition
now this is
in my view not a candidate for
executive session because of the immense
amendment that's going to be coming
forth to change the entire film
so we'll have to consider that next week
when we uh do the executive session
mr chair there is one new hand that is
raised from the attendees brody dushane
okay
yes this is uh representative de chase
from carol 6 which is wolfeboro new
hampshire uh representing one of the um
seats that is part of the carroll county
delegation
i wasn't going to testify but i will now
and i'm testifying in support of this
legislation the purpose of this
legislation is to create oversight that
requires our county to have competitive
contracts
right we've had a number of head
department heads that have contracted
the same supplier of services or goods
for now almost nearly uh over six years
without going to any competitive bid
process and so many of the delegates on
behalf of our taxpayers
saw that there was a need for
regulation to make sure that our county
was going through a competitive bid
process to save tax dollars and to save
tax money and to ensure that if we need
to make expenditures in other parts of
our county budget that we would be able
to shore up that kind of resources i
also would like to point out that the
state's power does indeed trump the
county's power so if the state wants to
regulate a county like in the existing
rsa for hillsborough county it can this
piece of legislation and the amendment
that would change the legislation is
perfectly constitutional it even though
it juxtaposes and um the commissioner
cited i believe it was rsa 30 that
doesn't matter if the state wants to
step in and decides that it is necessary
to regulate a county it can do so in a
number of ways and this is one way that
you know the courts have upheld and no
one has ever challenged the power of the
state to ensure that a county goes
through a competitive bid process so the
purpose of this bill is just to ensure
that our county administrators
and the commissioners
are having competitive bid processes for
any kind of expenditure that's more than
five thousand dollars and that would
also include delivery
so just to clarify everything and i am
supporting this nearly every um it's a
bipartisan bill
there's 10 of our delegates who are
currently on this piece of legislation i
believe it's 10 from carroll county
and my assumption is nearly all 15 of
our county delegates will be voting for
this legislation thank you
thank you very much
representative
uh we have uh another question from
cattle county i don't have a name on
that though i think that's still the
commissioners oh commissioners does
someone else from carroll county want to
is there someone on the phone now from
carroll county that would like to
this is executive coordinator melissa
siemens again i had nothing additional
i'm not sure if there's someone else
from our complex on the line
okay well thank
you welcome
there's a new handout from um i'm
matthew uh place is that how you
pronounce the name
happy flash europe yes it's it's pletch
um
so i'm a
carroll county commissioner
and uh was recently elected and
i've reviewed the bill and i have some
concerns
um i think it's an awfully cumbersome
process
uh
to go to the executive committee with
everything
any any contract over five thousand
dollars
uh there's a lot of service contracts
that we might not need to competitively
bid
based on
history and who we've been
been working with in the past and
knowledge of
of what needs to be done for the county
if if we have a service contract with
someone that's performing well
there's a value and continuity of
extending that contract
but
it's my understanding as i see it that
the county delegation
appropriates the funding
uh the commissioners
oversee the spending of the the money to
to carry out the business of the county
i i don't
feel the need
for the executive committee
to
[Music]
uh micromanage essentially every
contract
of five thousand dollars or more
it just seems like an overreach to me
and i don't know that it's going to be
it's going to create a lot of problems
and take a lot of time
to have every one of those
every one of those contracts reviewed a
second time after decisions have been
made
are there any questions for the
commission
answer no questions would anybody else
hey thank you uh
for the additional testimony i'm sorry
my computer decided it
had no more power so i had to go plug it
in
okay i'm going to be uh relying more on
representing my fury because
i'm i'm now blind to the
to the raising their hands so is there
anyone else that has
indicated they'd like to speak
um
mr or commissioner
place has his hands still up but i i
think that might be tough i think that
might be old there we go he's taking the
stand down so no sir no mr chair we did
not have any other pants up by either
the crimeless or the attendees
okay thank you very much uh
how can we say that we are now on
schedule
and uh our next hearing is going to be
at noon time
so i'm going to recess
this meeting for 10 minutes
i want to take a bathroom break or get a
drink of water
please feel free we will reconvene at 12
o'clock
mr chair i have a question before we go
yes is it all right if i ask it now
in the spirit of bipartisanship and i
really enjoy working with you i do have
a question about the process that we're
using
yeah this time
and
usually in the past in hearings a person
testifies and then the committee members
get a chance to question that person
before we move on to the next person
testifying um and
that process is different not the one
that we're using in this committee now
and i'm wondering if
i'm finding it kind of confusing and
wondering if this is the process we're
going to be using
from now on
it's a great question what i'm going to
do is before we leave for the day
i'm going to ask for a critique of how
the day went and that would be one of
the comments that you make
to see if we want to you know alter or
change the process going forward
all right i would welcome those comments
thank you very much mr chair for
listening thank you thank you mr family
mr chairman yes
yeah i've heard me pray here um
i'm obviously i'm at work and they're
closing down for the day so it's about
an hour commute from here to home
so i'm gonna
shut down and come back uh once i get
home
okay you can also if you have a a car
phone you can dial up
and uh and just and participate via
phone because we're not gonna be doing
any more executive sessions which
require the video so we're welcome to
participate by phone only also so we'll
just be taking testimony is that it yes
okay very good
mr chair
yes
hi it's ivy vann i also have a
procedural question
at the beginning of the day you said uh
that we should say whether we were
by ourselves or not by ourselves so
uh my husband i shoot him we both work
in the same
but i uh
shooed him out of the room and
i'm wondering and it's very cold where
he is now so my question is
is it possible for him to work at his
regular place across the room for me or
does he have to be in a different room
altogether no it certainly is possible
as long as that's disclosed we're fine
with that
okay i am disclosing that my husband is
working at the table across the room for
me
thanks
he'll be grateful
all right well uh
we will reconvene in eight minutes
and mr chair just seen though that again
procedurally
the reporting is going to continue we do
not stop recording it is still live
streamed if we do stop recording then we
lose the entire connection and therefore
consider your mic to still be yes that's
a very excellent reminder your mics are
hot and if there's something that you
might chat about privately that you
don't want to go out on the internet
consider that before you say it
all right we'll see you at noontime
simple
uh
i might drop in just to say hi to some
of them because i'm not in that
community at this time so that's right
there's some of the people that
okay
is
oh
well i think i might
be one of the oldest selectmen
yes i am
i had about three bad days
you must be one of the 99.8 percent to
survive
we're about to hear
house bill 560
and we've got representative peterson
uh from
ferry here to introduce the bill thank
you mr chairman
um i'm a co-sponsor of housewife 516 the
prime sponsor has a scheduling conflict
which has become the norm
in this building 560 is a bill to deal
solely with rockingham county it is a
change in the length of offices for a
number of positions
and as uh
as some of you may may have there is an
h the amendment
adds an omitted position of county
treasurer that was accidentally let off
left off the original writing of the
bill
the purpose of 560 is
multiple i happen to also sit on the
executive committee for rockingham
county and this is something that some
of us have spoken about and if you
notice the um
the co-sponsor list you'll see that with
the exception of senator boatswell they
are all members of the executive board
of the county
so representative ryan asked me to uh
bring a couple points for today to the
committee and the
points that i share as well so i will
provide those to you
once again silly affects rockingham
county
the the county has experience already
with four-year terms because our county
commissioners run on a rotating basis so
running a rotating
uh four-year term
is really not going to
be anything foreign to us
the public does not seem to have an
understanding of county government as
i'm sure you're aware
and when we have done recounts
over the years one of the things that
we've noticed is that county government
really does have a tendency to just not
be
something that folks like to fill in
uh we need to put this on a four-year
election cycle in the off year of the
presidential elections to give more
attention to these offices of the county
and we would hope that this the first
election affected by this law will be
the 2022
election all of these offices require
special qualifications or experience
for the county attorney
they must be an attorney typically with
prosecutorial experience the sheriff is
almost always someone with a law
enforcement background the register of
deeds is usually someone with experience
in researching and detailing deeds
the treasurer is almost always an
accountant
and although we went through the probate
for most cases only exists in the
constitution we should include that
office on here to be consistent
the third year term will give us more
stability in these offices and a chance
for long-range planning
the disruption of having to run every
other year is a distraction this change
will give us more efficient government
for rockingham county please let us try
to see if this is worthy of being
adopted
in a broad scan manner i had the
personal experience of spending some
time with the
county attorney
during the election period
and it's uh it's amazing the amount of
time that is required by these four
these are full-time county people
you know they're not like the delegation
that meets on a short-term basis and
then we go away these are folks that are
doing full-time work for the county and
they have to take a tremendous amount of
time out of their hands to run every two
years for office and at state reps we
can all appreciate the
requirement of having to run every two
years so that that's the gist of house
bill 560
and i'm i'm happy to take any questions
certainly that uh anybody may have
uh any questions from the members of the
committee uh representative
the first hand i saw went up with all
due respect to the representative who's
representative
yep
i don't have a question but i have a
disclosure we've entered the 1950s my
husband has come home for lunch
very open concept home so he'll be
eating his lunch and saying goodbye in
about half hour
all right make sure he chews with his
thank you for that disclosure
any anyone spell representative michelle
first yes representative
thank you mr chairman this seems to make
an awful lot of sense are there any
i absolutely don't know
i don't know where the counties do it
i've i'm a lifelong resident of uh
minus my college days and a little stiff
in the 70s in baltimore pretty much a
lifelong resident of rockingham county
so uh
and i honestly we're gonna we've been
our executive friend i've never had the
occasion to look to see what another
county does so that would be more uh
makes a lot of sense
it certainly does
any anyone else yes we uh the next stand
up is representative
yes please
thank you mr chair and mine is not a
question in terms of this but i think if
it is just one county
doing this
and you know it has to be uniform in
that sense right if you're changing an
election for one county and not the
i don't think that's a is that a
question to me yeah
um honestly um
i you know the rockingham county is a
legal subdivision in and of itself and
the actions of rockingham county are
are their own so
you know as far as any sort of statute
requiring that all counties do things in
a similar manner i'm not familiar with
with a statute that would say that so
you know this is something that the
rockingham county
officials wanted to bring forward and
certainly
if this works other counties are more
than welcome to
to jump on the bandwagon and this um
with the uh
primary and general elections for the
state and federal as well
yeah the
the hope was that uh and if you look at
the bill uh beginning of the election in
november of 2022 it would be a midterm
or what we would call a midterm election
cycle
for that rather than dropping that in
with the
with the presidential
election cycle that's great any any
other questions from
representative
thank you mr chair one of um
new hampshire doesn't have any ability
to recall
an elected official there's no recall
elections here and one of the reasons
that was was given when this issue came
up in the past one of the reasons that
was given is that because we have our
elections every two years if someone is
not functioning well or doing things
that are unacceptable and the voters
aren't happy with them they can just
vote them out
and that's why we don't have referendums
that's why we don't have recall
elections in new hampshire and i'm
wondering
you said your commissioners are voted in
for four-year terms
is that
accurate
the idea no um the idea is that the
commitment our commissioners run on a
rotating basis
and that was just as an example of how
the county handles
um
right elections beyond two years because
our commissioners do serve a longer term
than two years and it rotates
one of your commissioners does
uh several of the commissioners do it's
a staggered
okay but one at a time does
is that what you're saying yeah the
county commissioners are not up for
election at the same time with the
exception of
it happens eventually after
several cycles
the way that they're staggered
uh but for the most part they're they're
not replaced all at once that's a
continuity of government issue that the
county likes to maintain so that you
don't bring an entirely green board
into a into a executive role and plot
them down at one single time
so so can i continue my question mr
chair
go right ahead okay so
in a case where one of these elected
officials was um performing illegally or
doing something that they shouldn't do
there's no recourse to get them out of
office
um
prior to
their next election do they would
i guess i'm con that gives me a concern
about this so i'm wondering how you
would handle somebody who
was corrupt for example
if uh if uh an elected official of the
county level violence the law they would
be subject to prosecution
just just like anybody else
but they wouldn't be subject to
they would still be the elected official
that's a good question
because i i don't know if a judge could
position that
um
after a guilty finding of a criminal act
so
i guess the question would be what what
would cause an elected official to be
yes
and i don't know what we have in our
laws to allow that because we have
elections every two years
so thank you for taking my question i
mean you run the risk of that
certainly if someone's elected to a
two-year term and commits a crime
at the initial stages of their term
uh you know that that situation could
certainly exist already right so as you
know as far as the requirements go i
mean you know the we do have certain
requirements as far as eligibility for
office for folks that are convicted
felons and things like that so
attorney is one of the attendees but
does not
so uh
miss conway if you want to uh speak if
you could raise your hand and we would
recognize you
the same thing with sheriff massaso's if
if you're uh if you're online as well i
have you both asking to speak but
just no indication yet electronically
my attorney has her hand raised and i am
asking to fund you okay uh attorney
conway here yeah
hi good morning everybody see me
yeah
you can just hear me but you can't see
me is that how it works right
okay um
so in in terms of the issue we were just
discussing i i
i don't know i'd have to research that
particular issue in terms of
um if there's any statutory authority
that would allow
the public essentially to strip a person
of their position
however what i will say at least with
regard to the county attorney's office
is that
in order to
to be the county attorney you have to be
an attorney if you commit a crime
uh you could be potentially um disbarred
uh you could also be placed on leave
i know that some of you are probably
familiar with
before i became county attorney the
attorney general's office investigated
my predecessor
who
was basically
put on leave and we had an acting county
attorney
who was appointed
uh tim befetti who is an assistant
attorney general so um
that type of thing
occurred although mr reems was never
charged with anything uh criminally but
there were some allegations and there
was an investigation and there there is
a procedure in terms of how to deal with
that kind of thing
um in terms of the statutory provision
i'm just i'm not aware and i have to
look into that but
just in terms of support of the statute
i am in support of it i you know in
rockingham county we have about 41
people that work in this office we're
the largest law firm in rockingham
county
and
when an official such as myself has to
work every two years
it can create some disruption in the
office as you can probably imagine i
think you know my staff it creates some
some anxiety and a feeling of just
you know not knowing the future because
the reality is is the county attorney i
set the policies in the office
i'm responsible for making sure that
it's a positive work environment
i set the expectations for everyone in
my office in terms of what they need to
be doing
to do their job effectively and
when
i have to run for county attorney every
two years my staff they have no idea
what's going to happen and they don't
know who their boss will be
my employee employees also don't get
paid a ton of money
comparatively speaking in terms of if
they worked at a law firm
so having that kind of that sense of
sort of job security and knowing
you know what you're going to face in
the next
number of years as an employee i think
is important to the employees of of our
offices um and also i just if you look
at if you looked at a law firm like
maybe mclean or something in manchester
and you know the partners the partners
there don't
flip over every two years i mean that
would be crazy it would be crazy because
it would just cause so much disruption
to that that law office um
and so for the same reasons i
i
am in support of a four-year term rather
than two and it's also difficult to get
anything done in a office like this in
two years in terms of programming like
drug courts or veterans court
diversion i mean we might be able to
start things like that but to try to get
a court like that or a diversion program
going and really um becoming a solid
program for the citizens of our county
it's really difficult to do that in two
years and arguably it wouldn't be two
years because you know we have to start
campaigning
you all know how it is because your term
is two years but i mean basically you're
you're always campaigning you can never
stop
rockingham county is
towns in one city it's a huge geographic
area
and when you're campaigning obviously
you have to try to hit all of those
different towns in the city
we have to fundraise obviously to buy
signs and mailers and things like that
and it takes
a lot of time
to do that and it's time away from this
office it's time away from the
rockingham county attorney's office and
the work that we do here and i'm sure
you all know
we prosecute serious felony level
offenses um like rape like burglaries
like home invasions
um
serious violent assaults negligent
homicide
these are cases that are very important
to the citizens of our county i mean we
need to do a good job
we need to make sure that we're
professional in handling these cases
ethically and the county attorney should
be in the office
all the time to supervise the attorneys
to supervise the legal assistant to
supervise the victim advocates to
supervise the investigators
and to make sure that these cases are
being handled appropriately
um because we're talking about people's
lives we're talking about things we're
talking about their families and we're
also talking about defendants
you know we want to make sure that we're
handling cases fairly and we're treating
people
fairly and equally so
when we have to campaign
all the time essentially or you know
every other year it takes a tremendous
amount of time away from our job
responsibilities here in the office
[Music]
so i think that's really all i have to
say but i'm happy to answer any
questions
okay do we have uh
the sheriff available as well we do
might be ready to go okay sheriff you're
up
can you hear me all right yes perfectly
good i have to i have to agree with that
county attorney um
on everything that she said uh going
back to the
accountability
of uh elected officials um
i think
i mean being being a law enforcement
officer and being on police stands and
trains council
we have a high ethic for our law
enforcement personnel
um
i think if the sheriff
did something illegally uh number one
that we would lose our police stands and
we would lose our
certification a police certification
um
and i think at that point i mean you
would have to resign from that office
because you're technically not a law
enforcement uh officer
and there's
um
i don't know if there's any other
instances where other officials had to
resign for corruption
um but that's something that would have
to work out with you know
with the judges or whatever that if
someone did something wrong
part of the agreement was that you would
have to resign from your office
because i mean being the sheriff
you can't have a sheriff that's corrupt
i mean you know no one's above the law
and we're here to uphold the law of the
state of new hampshire
so i don't know if that helps you or not
but but getting back to
um
talking points on my office alone i mean
i'm coming off my first term and a
well-run organization
should have a clear and defined set of
long-term goals at least three to five
years
these goals help set the direction of
department operations by executing
short-term goals to accomplish the
desired uh long-term results uh two
years isn't is not
not sufficient time to successfully
envision implement and accomplish
accomplish long-range planning goals and
objectives
i campaigned on
enhancing a rockingham county drug task
force
and we've worked hard
to improve community relations
throughout the 37 towns in rockingham
county not only with law enforcement but
for the people that elected me as
sheriff
we find it that it takes time to reach
all 37 communities and reach out what
the sheriff's office does
and what we're
able to do to provide the best possible
law enforcement services around um just
our drug unit alone uh we had the
largest seizure of
fentanyl and state history but that was
you know that was a goal that took us
close to almost two years
to to make the arrest and get guilty
convictions and
you know and get this stuff off the
street and it takes a while to
enhance that unit and you work you know
together with all the chiefs
so they know what we're doing and stuff
like that
it just takes a lot of time
um law enforcement programs like i said
take time to implement sometimes they
require legislative actions coordinating
with multiple agencies and establishing
new policies
an effective way thought of our progress
could take years to
organize plan and execute you know a
longer term would allow our department
the opportunity to create more in-depth
programs to help better protect our
citizens
you know and it takes
it takes you know for new officials like
myself i mean i've been with the
sheriff's office for 40 years
so i know i basically know everybody
there their staff but as time changes
you get new personnel and new
administrative assistants assistant
administrative assistants i mean people
um they get promoted they get put in new
jobs and that's stuff that we all we
have to work with these people make sure
that they're doing doing the right thing
um
you know like i said it just takes times
it would it would be a lot easier for us
to have longer terms
as far as campaigning goes i agree with
the with the county
um attorney um
i mean right now i mean every four years
we're in on a presidential election now
on this term alone um we were actually
on the back of the ballot so people
aren't paying attention okay to the
count to the county uh officials that
are running for office i mean all of us
i mean most of the time we're on the
bottom of the ballot and by the time
people look at us
um
you know
it's it's hard for them to make a
decision they need to you know when the
when they're electing a president or you
know it's a big election you know i mean
at least they'll have time to to look
into us to see you know what we've been
doing for the last you know four years
or two years i mean two years now you
know um so i get a
and then you know plus campaigning i
mean rock dan county is is a big county
we have 37 communities i mean just
campaigning alone
to try doing the old-fashioned way of
going to parades and meeting people
going to meet and greets it takes up a
lot of time it takes up a lot of time
that's in my office where i could be in
my office concentrating on drugs an
active shooter and community police re
uh um
you know you know being a police
community police organization to get the
job done so
it's very important that
you know that we go to a four-year term
two years isn't enough time you know i
mean
two years is just not enough time so i
thank you sir that was
uh charles from the sejos for those of
you who uh
i've been recognizing the toys to be the
sheriff in rockingham money
uh is there is there anybody else that
doesn't handle it
uh of the aids kathy stacy i believe
correct one has uh
has hands up miss stacey the floor is
yours
just needs to unmute
can you hear me now
yes
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is kathy stacy i'm the
rockingham county register of deeds as
the committee should be aware i did send
in a written testimony to you i don't
want to
reiterate reiterate everything else
that's been said today but i i
absolutely ask you to support this bill
uh the question that was asked by one of
the representatives with regards to the
commission's district the commissioners
run so what happens is every third year
they get a four year term
so that's it's a is a rotation so that
we do have consistency in rockingham
county i think it's a wonderful thing
and it's actually another piece of
legislation that representative weiler
put in several years ago and quite a few
of the other counties have opted in to
that as well
i will just say that
i think it is important to have
consistency in the office my office is
quite busy and as you know i i have the
largest volume of records in the state
my records date back to 1629
and one of the biggest things obviously
is making sure that the public can
access those records
and during my tenure the most recent um
software changes that we made in
virginia's office it took me over three
and a half years
to get a conversion to get the product
tested and to get it out there for the
public it isn't something that can be
done in a year or two year it's a very
lengthy process and my concern obviously
would be if i left in the middle
um
that you know a year you know in every
year the second year you're spending a
lot of time
unfortunately campaigning
um which which sometimes takes you out
of the office and i am a hands-on
register i am here
every day i know every job that's in my
office and i can perform each job um and
i think it's important that you have
somebody who comes into
a position such as mine that has the
knowledge in the background and um you
know when you look at
surrounding states maine has a four-year
term for all their county elected
officials massachusetts has a six-year
term uh new jersey has a five-year term
new york and pennsylvania four years a
lot of the other states vermont and
connecticut but the town clerks um do
this service everything's done at the
local level for registry of d's that is
anyway um but you know i can't i can't
stress enough the fact that we have seen
when there's been issues with um an
official in rockingham county and
the uh
commissioners took charge and and things
got you know changed in that office and
the person was asked to leave and they
did they were locked out of the office
because of the
situation that was happening in that
office but uh other than that if you
have any questions for me i'm happy to
answer them and i appreciate your time
and ask you to support this bill thank
you
thank you miss stacy
is there any other questions from the
committee
uh representative gallagher you have
your hand up
so we've heard a lot of
points
in favor of
moving to for your election cycles but
one thing i'm still kind of unclear on
is
why this should only apply to rockingham
county
i was wondering if some of the people
should could answer the question of if
four-year election cycles are so good
why not extend them to the whole state
rather than having them just for
good question anybody online or whether
you
uh
we're under appearance and we want to
want to take a shot at that can you
still hear me mr chairman this is kathy
stacy yes
so my discussions with representative
weiler was he wanted to do this as a
pilot just as he did the commissioner
when he changed the commissioner's
districts
to see how it worked i mean obviously i
am sure that um and the new hampshire
and the legislative chair for the new
hampshire association of counties and
we're not meeting until this friday to
vote on
where we stand on various pieces of
legislation um mike you know i would
imagine you'll be hearing from us in the
near future
some counties probably will want to you
know if if if
you know that some may want to some may
not i don't know
uh however i know that representative
weiler's intention was to make this a
pilot see how it works see if it worked
well and then if other people wanted to
hop on just like the other piece of
legislation prior to this um to see how
it goes but that's that's pretty much
all i know about why uh he did what he
did
thank you that was a good clarification
anything else representative gallagher
um that will be
or yeah that's
fine for now yeah
okay any other questions from the uh
from the public or that be observing or
no sir
okay i think that's it then uh right
this bill will be
on the docket for next
next monday
very tech session excuse me
and at this point that concludes our
hearings for the day i would ask the
committee
not leave the meeting yet
unless you have uh
an urgent appointment elsewhere because
i'd like to
uh do a just a few minutes of critique
as to how the day went
and how uh you might suggest
to make improvements uh continuous
improvement is a goal of mine and and uh
i certainly would welcome
your comments at this point
thank you thank you
uh
still on the committee i see uh
representative matt cutie has her hand
up but i would again
uh i certainly would welcome your inputs
uh
we did some experimenting today we
we took some
uh testimony at the end for the
committee as uh representative porter
mentioned but we also
uh did a little bit of uh back and forth
between the committee and testifiers as
well
some of the other things that we did
today is
trying to stay on schedule by limiting
testimony uh by with with time frames
hopefully uh we still get everybody who
wanted to speak did get a chance to
there certainly were no filibusters
today
so
again i would like to hear your your
feedback i do know
that with one of our bills coming up
next monday
i'm anticipating a longer
uh period of testifying and for that
goal i scheduled an hour
as opposed to a half hour so
we'll see how that goes but uh let's
start with uh representative mitch
cooney
thank you mr chair i just want to say
thank you it felt so much more
comfortable doing the way we are doing
it
and i truly appreciate this openness and
inclusiveness i was a nervous wreck
before today
and this being my first uh
committee uh i mean first meeting with
this committee
and the second i would make a comment
about you know i am a creature of habit
in terms of blue sheet how many opposing
how many supporting not being able to
see that
virtually that would be something that
would help
me understand how this bill is received
outside
yeah i did get that from you and i
forgot to mention this the last bill
that we just
looked at we had support from seven
opposition for two
but i
know i'll try to
include that with
with each bill going forward
yeah and the last one is i think uh
this switching back and forth with exact
uh
was you know kind of interesting it was
good fresh in the memory but at the same
time for newbies like me at least for me
it was a little
quick but you know because there were a
few that were totally
no opposition that was fine but if it
was something that we're gonna do
if i know i had a time i would uh
prepare better thank you yes i think
this was a follow-up i'm trying to be
very cautious
for those few opportunities where we go
to execution right away
and uh if anybody objects to that
uh your objection whether it's one or
more
will prevent me from doing that i will
not uh try to force
executive session unless unless i it's
apparent to me that there's no
opposition to that
um and also consent calendar you've
heard me
uh make uh statements about without
opposition i'm gonna put this on consent
i have
the ability to do that when our votes
are 18 to 1
uh or 19 to zero if it's if there is
more opposition than one committee
member then there's not an option to put
it in the consent calendar
and
even if it goes in the consent calendar
any one of you
actually anybody in the house can
request that it be removed from the
consent calendar if you want to force a
debate on the floor
and talk to the bill more than just the
consent because for those of you that
are new a consent calendar basically
puts a bunch of bills that that are
pretty much unanimously either supported
or opposed
uh in the in our calendar that has that
blue sheet on it we don't haven't had
any of those yet because that usually
precedes
a meeting in representative hall or some
parking lot somewhere whatever we want
to do going forward
and
then what happens is the speaker asks
for a voice vote
on the consent calendar and all those
bills that are in the consent calendar
are either
uh accepted or rejected based on what
the committee recommended
most often uh unanimously
so that's just a quick lesson on what
that means consent challenge for the new
folks
all right uh next step at hand i have
thank you mr chairman for taking my
feedback first i concur with
representative majipudi regarding the
blue sheets and my second comment would
be this was done to some extent at the
beginning of this
hearing and meeting um
i would um ask prior to going live
perhaps the zoom moderator could sound
check all participants just to make sure
that we're clear and audible
feedback
i can tell you from
from uh
feedback that i've got from other chair
persons
that uh
their meetings in some cases were more
bumpy
than ours was because i think that our
assistants have
kind of learned the uh
the trade here a little bit and uh i get
becoming more proficient and i think us
as a committee will become more
proficient as well
uh as we uh as we tend to use this
process and learn from it uh and you get
to know me and and iu
in terms of uh
knowing when you want to speak and uh
what you might want to say
so uh again
uh i appreciate your feedback and let's
hear some more uh
thank you mr chair i think i think
everything went well even though my
computer actually exploded during part
of it
um
i want to follow up on representative
manjapudi's uh
discussion about the blue sheets
when we met in person or when we're all
meeting in person uh we can look at the
blue sheets and see who has signed up
and where they're from
and sometimes that helps if it's like a
fellow representative or someone from
your town or a neighboring town
so i don't i know we had one bill that
had 47 in in support so i don't want to
ask you to please read every name that's
on this on the blue sheets but it's but
if you could find out if there's some
way for us to get the list
uh that everybody's signing up for
electronically if they're coming in
remotely
to me
prior to the meeting so if i can get
them there's no reason why you can't get
them
all right that's right
let me see how uh how we would execute
that
uh
everything
yeah
okay
representative dan
um i was just going to say if you have
the sheet physically
you can screen share and show it to us
okay yes and you know and what i would
do is show it to us and say hey i'm
counting and it so that you know because
we're not going to be able to count fast
enough to tell who's for and who's again
so if you could show us the thing and
let us look at it for maybe 30 seconds
and say we have 46 people signed in on
opposition and 17 signed in and support
that might be the easiest way to manage
that
representative
that's something that
already
thank you mr chair um i think the
meeting was very well run i want to
especially commend you on
keeping people to their times especially
at the beginning of the meeting we sort
of got long at the end
but i think the not but and i think the
comment to the person testifying it you
know you have four minutes you have
three minutes you have this long and
then a warning it solidifies their
testimony and also
lets them know how important their
written testimony is as well
um i'm with representative porter
i'd like to consider that we try asking
people who are testifying before us
after they've testified
a few questions for them and then on to
the next person testifying because it
does get very confusing as to
who said what and who should i ask this
question for
my third thing is i really like seeing
the people who are here at the meeting
yet i know there are a few people who
are
maybe i'm assuming wrong in the room who
aren't
on the screen with us
um and i don't know if that's because
they don't have a computer in front of
them or an ipad or something like that
but i very much like seeing everybody
and i have to commend
representative mcbride on his faithful
following of our meeting
from his work in his car now to his home
very impressive and nice job everybody
else thank you
thank you
uh representative porter
thank you mr chair again i i don't i i
was uncomfortable not being able to ask
questions of a testifier right after
they made their testimony
um and i might get used to a new way but
i would i would feel comfortable if we
could try it the other way and let the
the committee decide that because we
have a lot of new members in this
committee
a lot of people who might not be
familiar with the law and the kinds of
things that we deal with and they might
need clarification on parts of bill's um
specific line items and that sort of
thing that would be awkward if we had to
wait if after the hearing two or three
people other than that i thought i
thought it went well and
it was interesting to see out and hear
all the little hums and dings and that
kind of stuff so
thank you for those comments i have made
a note and i will work
next monday to to do just that
uh
my uh
the
behavior today by me was
uh driven a little bit by trying to stay
on schedule and trying to maintain
the uh
the schedule that was published so that
we i've i have
uh observed
uh other committee members that
other committees that have gone very
long several hours past the
past day schedule and i certainly don't
want to uh
have this committee get into that mode
so so i'm i'm paying a little bit more
into how the meeting being run as
opposed to the content of the meeting
and so your comments are well taken and
let's let's experiment a little bit with
the other way
next monday and see how it's going so
just a word of um advice from a former
chair and someone who's sat on this
committee anything that has to do with
dogs or librarians you want to have a
long time for them because they all come
any other comments or critique that
you'd like to offer yes uh
i would just like to add to
representative porter's list
of
maybe longer testimony the subject of
but but i'd also like to just echo what
everybody has said representative dolan
uh i think that this was a exceedingly
well-run meeting and um and i think in
large part that is due to your efforts
as chair so thank you very much well
thank you we have uh at least one item
of administration
to deal with uh
we did the exact two bills as you
remember
and when we exec a bill we need to get a
majority uh write-up or a minority
write-up uh to the output of the bill so
uh i i would
actually lean on representative van
to write up uh the first bill her first
bill as to why we it feed it
and then uh we otp another bill and uh
john is that something that
is your bill i think
uh mr chair
i can write
i can write up the
blurb for the itl
or whatever we're calling them now
i know we're not supposed to call them
boys i know we're not i'll write up the
report and get it to you by tomorrow
thank you when you and please
also include representative mcdonald's
on that distribution of that report okay
great and you do you need the vote on it
it was 19. it was 18 to 0 because
somebody wasn't here yet should i
include that in my report
that would be fine
okay i can do that
representative
i was thinking i was gonna have to go
home and uh get on my computer to get
i'll sit close to the front next time
but uh
i i agree with uh representative porter
that uh
i
being able to answer questions
immediately after the testimony is
probably a better way but since you're
not bashful about uh telling people to
hurry up i think we can stay on schedule
right you know so uh i i agree it's a
good meeting
you know
thank you
those who know me from last year know
that i'm not bashful
but i also i'm i tend not to be impolite
and uh
in that in the bill that we had so many
uh
uh people testing fine on which was 586
we did hear from everybody who had asked
to testify which i was surprised that we
were able to get them all we went over
about an extra half hour
but uh
we would eliminate some people to a
minute to two minutes
which i'm sure they wanted more but but
representative porter's comment
it shows the importance of written
testimony being submitted
so that you don't you don't come and
testify for 15 minutes if all you're
going to do is read us
a two or three page single space
document it's much better to summarize
it in a minute or so and submit it in
writing and then we'll have the
opportunity to
to uh
to take our time and read them as they
get submitted
so uh
that's i think that's good feedback so i
think it's pretty unanimous that you'd
like to uh
try a little different way to
interrogate those testifying
and uh i've made myself a note
about that and uh oh i've made notes
about all your comments so we'll see
what i can do i know i made a note for
myself and that we need ac power up here
because my computer ran out of juice and
there's no place to plug it in so
i'll work on getting that fixed
uh
representative mattier you have your
hand down thank you mr chair i i just
thank you i just want to offer my
compliments uh not only to you for
running a very efficient meeting but to
the vice chair of representative
fiamonte
who ahead of this meeting worked with
our researcher christina dyer to make
sure that
those folks including myself and
representative laurel davis uh were at
least proficient and i'm not sure that
i'm there yet
running the orbeez being the tech people
for the zoomed portion of this and
without his diligence
i don't know that we would have uh it
might not have gone as smoothly so thank
you to representative piumati and with
great great thanks to christina docker
who is our researcher
for staying on top of this the entire
time yeah i'm confident that
by expecting a third meeting we're gonna
be flying uh really smooth
representative p monty had a comment
yeah i have uh one i just wanna know if
if everybody got the amendments to the
bills
just like anybody not that manchester uh
that were spoken operating he did or i
was going to do it
um
they were emailed two of them were
emailed i got
okay
the thing of it is they're supposed to
go through ann fitzgerald upstairs
anybody that has a bill and it creates a
an amendment
has to
get in touch with her because she's the
one that distributes distributed
distributes those
amendments right and um
i don't know if that was just done
properly or not right it will certainly
slow our executive sessions down if
committee members don't have the
amendments of being asked to vote on
them
uh we'll try to make sure that our tech
person in this case representative
maggiore has them at least so we can
screenshot them but i think that that is
a uh
a minimal
uh
solution because it really doesn't give
you a chance at a screenshot to read
through an amendment that's that's might
be uh single spaced and maybe multiple
pages long so we'll try to get them in
your hands if they're not
uh you know i'll certainly entertain
uh
comments from the committee to push to
postpone a hearing or an executive
session where you don't have the
documentation
that you need to make the decisions that
you're asked to make so
we'll work hard on that uh we'll talk
with
uh especially miss goalie is the
um
is the assistant that really handles our
documentation more than
than dyer uh ms dyer
kind of handles the electronic
communication and the zoom part of it uh
but as far as the documentation goes
uh it's goalie is the one as she was
last year she does usually a very good
job so
we'll see if we can try to make sure if
you if you are missing documentation
please please please don't hesitate to
say i don't have it i need it
uh and
because i don't want to put you at risk
of having to vote on something that
you're not fully informed on
so we'll work very hard to make sure you
get that or we'll postpone the meeting
any uh any more comments or is it time
for lunch for everybody yes
i have one thing if i could okay um
in the room for representative country
thank you uh
i
comment on getting information i get my
email to my private email i don't use
the state email and every once in a
while it goes to the wrong place so
that might be the case i never received
anything that comment was from
representative guthrie and you should
know
with the if you want to send something
to representative guthrie
you know on the updated
email list that i sent out for the
committee roster he has a special
email that he uses that's his private
email rather than his legislative email
same with
uh
representative porter and representative
gallagher
use a different email if as well so
uh you can you can always send it to the
legislative email but if you really want
to get their attention for those three
committee members also
add in their private email
also
this is still being recorded on youtube
it might be better for him to email
mrs
i emailed it to you
okay
yeah but if you need it i'll give it to
to send a new email
okay
either my private email or my
legislative email i didn't phone so if
you just if you just email your your uh
uh
your
preferred phone number
uh
uh well i'll add a list so you know it's
on the list
there's a couple of blank spots on there
even if you did it before send it to me
again
but i may have missed it and that those
emails those older emails may end up in
uh
in an electronic trash bar or something
yeah
mr chair yes i just want to include
myself in those other folks who don't
have legislative email
i have a private email that i use and i
think you've got it
on your list
okay
very good
all right
mr timmy mr chairman uh representative
tripp in the room yes
mr chair
uh
i don't believe that i got the
instructions for the zoning
uh
do you think that it would be possible
that uh you could let us know when we
should expect to get the
there's no needing instructions so that
if
you don't get them that we know that uh
they've been
they should have been sent out yes uh
you you typically get them the day
before or two days before
uh i haven't got it
today
before or two days before
i should not have to yeah
and
on typically on friday you get the
calendar with uh with the blue sheet on
the front i got that uh some of you get
electronically some of you if you
blocked it in you also get a hard copy
the zoom instructions are in the
calendar
oh
so
they said they are going to send them
well i think you also should be getting
an electronic
invitation of the panelists to the zoom
but if you don't get that with uh then
that easily comes the day before
because
many folks
uh
if you're like me you get so many emails
that if you get it a week before it's
it's 40 or 50 emails
uh too low for you to see anymore so
it's usually set the day before but
uh
let me ask
uh representative
andrea to see if you can help making
sure that uh everyone gets the
assumed invitation and even if we have
to give it several times
just take the latest one because they
all should be the same yes i believe the
zoom invite for that's in the uh
calendars is for people who want to
testify
because if
if you're not a panelist you really
can't speak well what happens is uh if
you zoom in through that link
a tech person here in this case
representative imaginary
uh
elevates you to a panelist oh as the
meeting starts
i didn't know that yeah
we're not learning that and i have to
get elevated to be a
co-host
so if i have some control as well also i
committed some panelists without any
control so
we're all learning
the nuances of the
electronic uh
unfortunately it would be so much better
if we could do this in person i i think
i've been so much more
sitting across the lunch table in the
cafeteria
uh talking to people about how they feel
about things that were unfortunately not
getting these days but hopefully keeping
our fingers crossed with enough
vaccinations maybe we can get back to
that i get my vaccine today
like at least my first shot so
that's good that's because i'm not old
and i had the appointment about eight
days later
i don't know if it's that fast anymore
lunch
lunch truck
no that's fine
okay thank you welcome back we are done
for the day correct yes we're done for
the day we know exactly this afternoon
it won't be as leisurely on next monday
because we have meetings after lunch to
do executing of those bills that we
heard today that we did not yet exact so
this uh let's say we heard
seven bills
so we'll have five to accept uh next
monday afternoon yeah just on the
vaccine side if there is a public health
department if you sign up on their
website uh the way i got it was it was
uh over uh you know more about 150 doses
that was uh going to expire or
go to waste so they called in the last
minute in fact i got a text at 1 30 a.m
from the public health department
to see if i would come in with my
husband the following day
and i happened to be awake at 3 30 a.m
and i responded and i got on the list so
good for you sounds fine lucky yes is
tonight right bad joke of my part so all
right thank you very much i'm going to
close the meeting at this point and
we'll see you next monday
thank you
[Music]
bye
it's still recording just in case
christina said she's gonna shut
everything down so i'm just just so you
know it's still recording being mindful
well i set my doctor's appointment for
tuesday
oh and you scheduled a meeting so next
week
what i did is i talked to the chief of
staff and speaker's office and said
you've got to get me
a day
during the vacation week
uh so i helped him all week and what he
did
give me a day
thank you yeah
which i think turned out to be the
tuesday after the monday i thought i
thought i did
like
my vaccine schedule for tomorrow
and because of the snowstorm they
they moved in
i was gonna they're gonna work on four
there's one thing i've learned from
being in the military if you keep your
expectations low enough you'll never do
this
that i asked her to send out a hard copy
of everything
because i wasn't sure who was coming and
who
uh downstairs and see joe